I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Hi.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量的闺蜜故事，带你更深入地了解《办公室》的世界。我们是Office Ladies 6.0。你好。嗨。
How's it going? It's going so good. It is? Yeah. Same. It's just a beautiful day. I'm sitting across from my friend. And my frowned.
最近怎么样？非常好。是吗？对。一样。这真是美好的一天。我正坐在我的朋友对面。和我的皱眉对面。
Oh, that's how I would talk to my kitty cat. I know, you're saying my frowned. And also, we're doing something that's kind of touching my heart this morning. I'm so excited. We're finally doing it. Okay, so here's what's happening. We are going to break down the paper scam alert, episode five. But first, you guys, we're going to kick things off with and around the town.
哦，那是我跟我家小猫说话的方式。我知道，你在说“我的皱眉”。而且，今天早上我们正在做一件有点触动我心弦的事。我太兴奋了。我们终于要做了。好吧，事情是这样的。我们要剖析《关于纸张的骗局警报》，第五集。但首先，伙计们，我们要从一个“走街串巷”环节开始。
Woo-hoo! This is the segment we've been wanting to do. You guys remember in our breakdown of episode two of the paper, I shared about my grand Mother Lena's hometown newspaper column. She would document little slice of life moments happening in my hometown of Archer City, Texas. And we just loved this idea. I loved it so much. So we decided to make it part of our show. And we asked you all to send in your Around the Town tidbits and moments. And we're going to start sharing them in these episodes as we continue to break down the paper. Yeah. And since this is the first one, we thought we'd kick off the episode with it.
呜——呼！这是我们一直想做的环节。大家还记得在我们剖析《关于纸张》第二集时，我分享了我外祖母莉娜的家乡报纸专栏吗？她会记录发生在我德克萨斯州阿彻城家乡的生活琐事。我们太喜欢这个主意了。我太喜欢了。所以我们决定把它作为我们节目的一部分。我们邀请大家发送你们的“走街串巷”趣闻和时刻。随着我们继续剖析《关于纸张》，我们将在这些剧集中开始分享它们。是的。既然这是第一期，我们觉得就用它来开启这一集吧。
All right, here we go, office ladies reporting for Around the Town. This one is from Kathleen in Newton, Kansas, and Kathleen put her around the town in the newsy jargon. Oh, I love it. Like the way your grandma wrote them. Here is what she said. Miss Kathleen Bergman and her mother, Mrs. Robert Bergman, started the new year with a visit to the Van Gogh experience in Wichita, followed by Lunch at the Dairy Queen. Lunch at the DQ? I love lunch at the DQ.
好了，我们开始吧，“办公室女士”为您报道“走街串巷”。这一条来自堪萨斯州牛顿市的凯瑟琳，凯瑟琳用新闻行话写了她的“走街串巷”。哦，我太喜欢了。就像你奶奶写的那样。她是这样说的。凯瑟琳·伯格曼小姐和她的母亲罗伯特·伯格曼夫人以参观威奇托的梵高体验展开启了新的一年，随后在冰雪皇后（DQ）享用了午餐。在DQ吃午餐？我太喜欢在DQ吃午餐了。
You too. Are you kidding? Not dinner. Lunch. There's something about eating it at lunch. Well, why is that? Why is it better? It's so great.
你也是？开玩笑吧？不是晚餐。是午餐。午餐吃这个有一种特别的感觉。好吧，为什么呢？为什么这样更好？太棒了。
I don't know. I love their, any of their baskets. You know, their chicken finger basket and the gravy with the French fries and the toast. Oh. I know. All right. Well, next up, this is from Trista Inn in Alberta, Canada. She says, I live in a small town in Alberta, Canada, called
我不知道。我喜欢他们的，他们的任何套餐。你知道，他们的鸡柳套餐，还有配炸薯条和吐司的肉汁。哦。我懂。好吧，接下来，这是来自加拿大阿尔伯塔省的崔斯塔。她说，我住在加拿大阿尔伯塔省的一个小镇，叫
Moranville. We used to have this beautiful Catholic church that was built in 1907, but unfortunately, it burned down in 2021. Before it was burnt down, the church bells used to ring all the time, and it was just such a cozy feeling. It took some time to rebuild it, and the church bells finally rang once again after almost five years yesterday. It was such a great feeling to hear them ring again. Wow. Isn't that so special? Yeah. I mean, that's That's meaningful. Yeah. That they rebuilt them and to hear them ring.
莫兰维尔。我们以前有一座美丽的罗马天主教堂，建于1907年，但不幸的是，它在2021年被大火烧毁了。在被烧毁之前，教堂的钟声总是响个不停，那种感觉真是太温馨了。重建它花了一些时间，昨天，在将近五年之后，教堂的钟声终于再次敲响了。再次听到它们敲响，那种感觉真是太棒了。哇。是不是很特别？对啊。我的意思是，那很有意义。对。他们重建了教堂，并再次听到钟声。
Throughout the town. It just feels like such a, I don't know, very poetic, symbolic of, you know, rebuilding. Rebuilding. Yeah. All right. Elizabeth P. from Bellingham, Washington said, so we have a lot of large, tall trees along the freeway up here. Someone put a giant sloth way up in one of the trees.
回荡在整个小镇。感觉就像是，怎么说呢，非常具有诗意，象征着，你知道的，重建。重建。对。好吧，来自华盛顿州贝灵汉的伊丽莎白·P说，我们的高速公路沿线有许多又大又高的树。有人在其中一棵树的高处挂了一只巨大的树懒。
And you could see it from the freeway as you. drive north? Well, the Washington State Department of Transportation took it down. But that did not dissuade the good people of Bellingham from bringing the sloth spirit back. After several back and forths of the sloth going up and WSDOT taking it down, the mystery sloth person somehow managed to get the sloth to new heights so that it could not be brought down. So slothy has been up there ever since and has a spotlight lit up on him somehow at night for all to easily see him from the freeway. Slothy lives on. That is so amazing to me. It's kind of great that I guess the Washington State Department of Transportation was like, well, it's high enough up now. It's safe. They love it.
你开着车往北走时，从高速公路上就能看到它？好吧，华盛顿州交通部把它取下来了。但这并没有打消贝灵汉好市民们带回树懒精神的积极性。经过好几个回合的树懒挂上去而华盛顿州交通部又把它取下来之后，这位神秘的树懒人士不知怎么设法把树懒挂到了更高的高度，让它无法被取下来。所以树懒从那以后就一直呆在那里，到了晚上不知怎么的还用聚光灯照着它，这样大家从高速公路上都能轻而易举地看到它。树懒永存。这对我来说太神奇了。华盛顿州交通部大概觉得，好吧，现在挂得够高了。它很安全。他们很喜欢它。
Clearly, it has its own spotlight. We're leaving it. I guess so. I want to drive by it. Well, thank you guys all so much for writing in your around the towns. We'll keep sharing. sharing these as the weeks go by. Yeah, you can find the folder to share on officeladys.com around the town. I feel like my grandmother would be so proud. Well, now it is time for our chit-chat question of the week, and it's coming from Amy H in Santa Clarita, California. I might have had a hand in selecting this one. You did. Hi, I've been a faithful listener since day one and absolutely loved the show. I used to be up in the middle of the night pumping for my baby girl, and I would listen to the office ladies or rewatch an episode of the office. It honestly brought me so much joy during postpartum and through
显然，它有自己的聚光灯。我们不管它了。我想也是。我想开车从它旁边路过。好吧，非常感谢大家写信分享你们的“走街串巷”。随着时间的推移，我们会继续分享这些内容。是的，你可以在 officeladys.com 的“走街串巷”版块找到投稿文件夹。我觉得我奶奶会为之骄傲的。好了，现在是我们本周的闲聊问答时间，这个问题来自加利福尼亚州圣克拉里塔的艾米·H。我可能在这道题的选择上出了点力。确实有。嗨，我从第一天起就是忠实听众，并且非常喜欢这个节目。我过去经常在半夜起来给我的宝贝女儿吸奶，我会听《办公室女士》或者重温一集《办公室》。在产后和经历
COVID. So thank you so much for that. Jenna and Sam, you've mentioned that you both lift weights. What do your workouts usually look like? Thanks again for all your laughs and heart you've put into the show. You all feel like friends at this point. Oh, Amy, Amy, Amy, Amy. I love to talk about weightlifting. You do. You get real sort of, I don't know, like that perky face. Percy face. Percy face. I would love to give an update on my weightlifting. I've been weightlifting for over a year now, and I am so passionate about it. I weightlift with Body Fit by Amy. You're inspiring me that 2026 is going to be the year I waitlift because of you. Really? Yes. I'm so excited. You leave me such great messages about it, and it makes you feel so
新冠疫情期间，它真的给我带来了巨大的快乐。非常感谢你们带给我这一切。珍娜和萨姆，你们提到过你们两个都举重。你们的锻炼通常是什么样的？再次感谢你们为节目带来的欢笑和真心。到现在为止，你们感觉就像朋友一样。哦，艾米，艾米，艾米，艾米。我喜欢谈论举重。你确实喜欢。你整个人会变得，我不知道，那种兴高采烈的样子。生动的脸。生动的脸。我很乐意介绍一下我举重的最新进展。我举重已经有一年多了，我对它充满了热情。我是跟着“Amy的身体塑形（Body Fit by Amy）”进行举重的。你给了我灵感，让我觉得因为你，2026年将成为我举重的一年。真的吗？是的。我太激动了。你给我发了那么多关于这方面的精彩信息，它让你感到非常有
empowered. I'm like, I want to get on this train. Listen, after breaking my shoulder and all that cancer treatment, I am stronger physically than I've ever been in my life. Because I used to work out, but my workouts were always, I mean, if I'm being honest, they were all geared toward burning calories, losing weight, maintaining weight. But the weightlifting is about something else. It's about being physically strong and capable in my body. And for me, it's also about, you know, making me have less side effects from my medications because it's been proven that that really helps. And I'm like, I can't say enough great things about it. I love it. And I want to say I have been lifting weights for over a year with no change on the number to the scale. This is really about
力量。我就想，我也要加入这个行列。听着，在肩膀骨折和经历所有癌症治疗之后，我身体的强壮程度是我这辈子从未有过的。因为我以前也锻炼过，但我的锻炼总是，说实话，都是为了消耗卡路里、减重、维持体重。但举重关乎别的东西。它关乎让我在身体上变得强壮和有能力。对我来说，这也关乎，你知道的，让我减少药物的副作用，因为事实证明这真的很管用。我觉得，我对它的好赞不绝口。我太喜欢了。我想说，我举重一年多了，体重秤上的数字没有任何变化。这真的是为了
strength. This is really about like being capable. Yeah. But I have lost an inch and a half in my waist. Hey. Yeah. So it's like things. are like reforming. Mm-hmm. You're like a transformer. A little bit. A little bit. Disguise.
力量。这真的关乎拥有能力。是的。但我的腰围瘦了一英寸半。嘿。对。所以就像是身体。在重塑。嗯哼。你就像个变形金刚。有点像。有点像。伪装。
Sam, what about you? Are you? You're still weightlifting, right? Yeah, still weightlifting, yeah. So I've been doing CrossFit is what I've been doing. And it's super easy to make fun of, and you should because people that do CrossFit are crazy. But it's really, really cool. What's CrossFit?
萨姆，你呢？你还在举重吧？对，还在举重，是的。我一直在做的是CrossFit（高强度综合体能训练）。这超级容易被拿来开玩笑，你也应该这么做，因为练CrossFit的人都疯了。但它真的很酷很酷。什么是CrossFit？
Sam, can I say that I used to meet a group of friends for brunch and we'd be having like the biggest pancakes and bacon and mimosas and the cross-fit group in the valley would go running past us, like holding like tires and shit. Yeah, so it's super brutal. It's one of those like, how do I describe it? It's definitely geared towards single guys in their 40s. But it's like a lot of cardio and weightlifting together. So it's like sets of things.
萨姆，我能说我以前经常和一群朋友去吃早午餐，我们会吃超级大的煎饼、培根和含羞草鸡尾酒，而山谷里的那个CrossFit训练小组会从我们身边跑过，手里还拿着轮胎之类的破玩意儿。对，所以这超级残酷。它是那种，我该怎么形容呢？它绝对是针对40多岁的单身汉设计的。但它有点像大量的有氧运动和举重结合在一起。所以它是一组一组的项目。
You'll do five sets of running a mile and then 100 burpees and then 50 sit-ups. You'll do that five times. Oh, my God. What? Yeah. That's intense. I once did a burpee challenge where you're supposed to do one burpee each day, but then you increase by one for 30 days. So you start with one. Who challenged you to do this? The internet. Oh, Lord. Social media. Oh, my gosh. And by the end of the challenge, you know, by the end of the month, you're doing 30. I feel like I've told this story before. I threw my back out on day three. Did three burpees and I was done. That was it for me. Oh, my God. But I wonder, could I do? I'm afraid to try. Don't mess with it.
你要做五组跑一英里，然后做100个波比跳，然后做50个仰卧起坐。你要把这套做五遍。哦，天哪。什么？对。这太激烈了。我曾经做过一个波比跳挑战，要求你每天做一个波比跳，然后连续30天每天增加一个。所以你从一个开始。谁挑战你做这个的？互联网。哦，天哪。社交媒体。哦，天哪。到挑战结束时，你知道的，到月底，你得做30个。我觉得我以前讲过这个故事。我在第三天就把背给扭了。做了三个波比跳，我就完事了。我当时就那样了。哦，天哪。但我很好奇，我能做到吗？我不敢尝试。别去招惹它了。
Just keep lifting my heavy dumbbells, kettlebells and things. I told Josh, I was like, Jenna's really inspired me to weightlift. And he was like, son of a bitch, I've been telling you how healthy it is and how good it is for you. He's very physically fit. And he has a very structured weightlifting thing that he does. He does legs. It's leg day. He does arm day.
就继续举我的重哑铃、壶铃这些东西吧。我告诉乔希，我说珍娜真的启发了我去举重。然后他说，这个混蛋，我一直在跟你说这有多健康，对你有多好。他身体非常健美。他有一套非常结构化的举重计划。他练腿。今天是练腿日。他练手臂。
He does this every day, no matter where we are. Well, here's the thing with weightlifting, too. Does Josh eat like a ton of protein, Sam? Are you like, like I can't with the protein? I don't even understand. He does. All I eat is chicken breasts, broccoli and brown rice. Yeah.
他每天都这么做，不管我们在哪里。好吧，举重还有一点，乔希是不是吃大量的蛋白质，萨姆？你会不会觉得，就像我受够了蛋白质一样？我甚至都不明白。他是的。我吃的只有鸡胸肉、西兰花和糙米。对。
It's disgusting. Josh eats so much protein. And sometimes I'm like, I need a break. Give me some shrimp. Does shrimp have protein? Yeah. But you know what I mean? I need a break from the chicken.
太恶心了。乔希吃了超级多的蛋白质。有时候我就想，我需要休息一下。给我来点虾。虾有蛋白质吗？有。但你知道我的意思吗？我需要从鸡肉里解脱出来。
Yeah. The chicken, the chicken. Yeah. I found these protein. shakes. They're mega protein. I think they have like 32 grams per shake or something. How do they taste? I like them. They were very low rated on a shake tasting article I read. Sure. But there are complaints about the shake were all the things I liked about it. They're like, it's a little thin and watery. And I'm like, easy to drink. I like it. I don't want like a super thick dairy shake. This is a
对，鸡肉，还是鸡肉。对。我找到了这些蛋白质。奶昔。它们是超级蛋白质。我想它们每杯奶昔大概有32克蛋白质什么的。味道怎么样？我挺喜欢的。在我读到的一篇关于奶昔口味测评的文章里，它们的评分很低。确实。但对这款奶昔的投诉全都是我喜欢它的地方。他们说，它有点稀，像水一样。而我觉得：容易喝。我喜欢。我不想要那种超级浓稠的奶制品奶昔。这是一种
non-dairy plant-based protein. They said it tastes a little chalky. It's a little chalky. It's doesn't bother me. Okay, we'll have to share it. You want some of my watery chalky shake? No, I don't. But someone listening might, Amy might like to know about it. Yes, Angela, will you put my shake in stories? Your watery chalky shake? Yes, I love personally. I like both the vanilla and the chocolate. And speaking of people named Amy, I want to give a plug to my trainer, Amy, who I now work out with in person, but for like four years, I just did her videos on YouTube until I was hiking one day. And she was like, Jenna, I'm Amy.
非乳制品的植物性蛋白质。他们说它尝起来有点粉状。有点粉状。这不困扰我。好吧，我们得分享一下。你想尝尝我那如水般粉状的奶昔吗？不，我不想。但听众里可能会有人想，艾米可能会想了解一下。是的，安吉拉，你能把我的奶昔发到快拍里吗？你那如水般粉状的奶昔？对，我个人很喜欢。香草和巧克力我都喜欢。说到名叫艾米的人，我想为我的教练艾米打个广告，我现在跟她进行线下训练，但大约四年来，我只是在YouTube上跟着她的视频练，直到有一天我去徒步旅行。然后她对我说：“珍娜，我是艾米。
I'm body fit by Amy. You post my videos on your Instagram. And I was like, what? You live here? She's like, yeah, I live here. She's like, do you want to come work out with me sometime? I know this story, but I love it every time you tell it because it was so meant to be. It was so meant to be.
我是‘Body Fit by Amy’。你在Instagram上发过我的视频。”然后我说：“什么？你住在这里？”她说：“对啊，我住在这里。”她说：“你想不想什么时候跟我一起锻炼？”我知道这个故事，但每次你讲我都还是很喜欢，因为这真是命中注定。这真是命中注定。
And I love her. And she's just so like, I mean, half of our training sessions are just her, like, deprogramming my negative brain thoughts about your body. Yes. Yeah. You know, like she's like part therapist and her whole Instagram and all of her YouTube videos, they have that same energy. I adore her. Well, I'll share her account as well. And I don't weight lift, but I do run my ass off every week because I play a lot of tennis. Yeah. And I do squats. So one of the ways I warm up is I will do squats like the length of one side of the court. Yeah. And then we just run.
我太喜欢她了。她就是那种，我的意思是，我们一半的训练时间都是她在帮我，消除我大脑中对你身体的负面消极想法。是的。对。你知道，就像她扮演了一部分治疗师的角色，她的整个Instagram和她所有的YouTube视频，都带着那种同样的能量。我太崇拜她了。好吧，我也会分享她的账号。我不举重，但我每周都拼命跑步，因为我打很多网球。对。我还做深蹲。所以我的热身方式之一就是沿着球场一侧的长度做深蹲。对。然后我们就跑。
We just run a lot because we're really aggressive. That's where your legs are so nice. Thanks, lady. Angela has great legs. Oh, thank you. She always has. Oh, thanks. Thank you, tennis.
我们就是大量地跑，因为我们真的很好胜。这就是你的腿为什么那么好看。谢谢你，女士。安吉拉的腿很好看。哦，谢谢。她一直都很好看。哦，谢谢。谢谢你，网球。
Well, look at that. I just want to note that I've made it into stories twice, and we haven't even taken our first break yet. My shake and body fit by Amy. Jen, I want you to know forever that we podcast. You can be in stories anytime you want. Well, I'm trying, in the new year, I'm trying to contribute more to our stories. All right.
瞧瞧这个。我只想说，我还没开始第一个休息环节，就已经两次登上快拍了。我的奶昔和“Body Fit by Amy”。珍娜，我想让你永远知道我们做播客这件事。你随时都可以登上快拍。好吧，我在努力，在新的一年里，我努力为我们的快拍贡献更多内容。好吧。
It's a little goal of mine. All right. All right. We'll take a break and we'll be back. We're breaking down season one, episode five, scam alert of the paper. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, just because it's a new year, that does not mean you have to be a new you. But maybe you want to be a less burdened you, a clearer you.
这是我的一个小目标。好吧。好吧。我们休息一下，一会儿回来。我们正在剖析第一季第五集，《关于纸张》的“骗局警报”。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。你知道，新年新气象并不意味着你必须脱胎换骨变成一个崭新的人。但也许你想成为一个少一些负担的自己，一个思绪更清晰的自己。
Not a totally new you, but maybe like you just want to hone in. You want to refine. Yeah. I like that. Refine. Well, therapy can help more easily identify what is weighing you down, what might be holding you back. You can better understand your relationships, your motivations, your emotions. I'm trying to let go of just sort of stressing about the small things. Mm-hmm. Because those really just add up. Mm-hmm.
不是一个全新的你，但也许就像你想专注其中。你想变得更精致。对。我喜欢这个。精致。嗯，心理咨询可以帮助你更容易地识别是什么在拖累你，是什么可能在阻碍你。你能更好地理解你的人际关系、你的动机、你的情绪。我正试图放下对小事的焦虑。嗯哼。因为那些积少成多，真的很烦人。嗯哼。
And they're going to be just fine. Well, and you might need help identifying what are. small things, what are big things. BetterHelp therapists can help. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally. BetterHelp makes it easy to get matched online with a qualified therapist. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's better, H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. I'm Emigreed, host of Aspire with Emigre, a podcast where I sit down with people who don't just dream big, they build big.
而且它们都会没事的。嗯，你可能需要有人帮你辨别什么是小事，什么是大事。BetterHelp的心理咨询师可以帮忙。拥有超过3万名咨询师，BetterHelp是全球最大的在线心理咨询平台，已为全球超过500万人提供过服务。BetterHelp让你轻松在网上匹配到合格的咨询师。注册并在 betterhelp.com/officeladys 上获得10%的优惠。网址是 betterH-E-L-P.com/officeladys。我是埃米·格里德（Emigreed），《与埃米·格里德一起向往》（Aspire with Emigre）的主持人。在这个播客中，我与那些不仅敢于梦想大业、而且真正付诸宏大建设的人进行深入交流。
From culture-shaping voices like Mel Robbins to leaders redefining success like Tracy Ellis-Ross to game-changing entrepreneurs like Mark Cuban, Aspire is about mindset, ambition, and doing the work that actually moves the needle. If you're ready to raise your standards and take charge about the life and career you're building, Aspire is where you start.
从塑造文化的梅尔·罗宾斯（Mel Robbins），到重新定义成功的领袖特雷西·埃利斯·罗斯（Tracy Ellis-Ross），再到改变游戏规则的企业家马克·库班（Mark Cuban），《Aspire》探讨的是思维模式、野心，以及如何采取真正能推动变革的行动。如果你准备好提高标准，主导你正在构建的生活和职业生涯，那么《Aspire》就是你起步的地方。
Follow and listen to Aspire with me, Emma Greed, an Odyssey podcast available wherever you get your podcasts. We are back and like we said, we're doing season one, episode five of the paper, scam alert. This episode was written by Mo Welch, who also plays Kimberly on the show. Mo, hilarious writer-performer, and we got to exchange messages with her. She's so fun. Yes.
关注并收听由我——埃米·格里德主持的《Aspire》，这是一个奥迪西（Audacy）播客，你可以在任何收听播客的地方找到它。我们回来了，正如我们所说，我们要讲的是第一季第五集《关于纸张》的“骗局警报”。这一集由莫·韦尔奇（Mo Welch）编剧，她还在剧中饰演金伯利。莫是一位搞笑的编剧兼演员，我们有机会跟她互发了信息。她太有趣了。是的。
We reached out. She was very quick to give credit to the whole room of writers for helping to shape this episode. She said the room is very collaborative. Everyone has a hand in the final script. She specifically shouted out fellow writer Ben for, helping to provide a window into online dating. That's a big part of this episode.
我们联系了她，她非常爽快地将功劳归于整个编剧团队，感谢大家帮助构思这一集。她说编剧室非常有合作精神。每个人都对最终的剧本出了一份力。她特别大声感谢了同僚编剧本（Ben），感谢他帮忙为网上约会提供了一个窗口。这是这一集很大的一部分。
Yeah. She said, quote, I'm a married lesbian. Sorry to expose you, Ben, but he was a big help. Is Ben hitting the dating apps? I guess so. Writer Ben on the apps. This episode was directed by Taspa Chavez. Okay, this was a big get.
是的。她说，原话是：“我是个已婚女同性恋。对不起，暴露了你，本，但他真的帮了大忙。”本在玩约会软件吗？我想是的。编剧本在玩软件。这一集由塔斯帕·查韦斯（Taspa Chavez）导演。好的，这可是一个大牌导演。
I am so impressed. Taspa is the co-exec producer of Reservation Dogs for which she received an Emmy nomination, a Peabody Award nomination, as well as two WGA Awards. There are lots of connections to office folks. She was a writer on Ed Helms' series, Rutherford Falls. And she directed the Sex Lives of College Girls and now the paper. Oh, that's very office-centric. So we've got kind of a powerhouse here with our writer and director of this episode.
我太佩服了。塔斯帕是《救赎犬》（Reservation Dogs）的联合执行制片人，她凭借该剧获得了艾美奖提名、皮博迪奖提名以及两个WGA（美国编剧工会）奖。这里面有很多和《办公室》工作人员的联系。她是埃德·赫尔姆斯（Ed Helms）的剧集《拉瑟福德瀑布》（Rutherford Falls）的编剧。她还导演了《大学女生性生活》（The Sex Lives of College Girls），现在又导演了《关于纸张》。哦，这非常有《办公室》的核心风格。所以我们这位这一集的编剧和导演可以说是强强联手。
Are you ready for a summary? I live for it. Here it is. In this episode, Ned pursues a juicy, catfishing story only to discover that Esmeralda is one of the victims. Oh, poor Esmeralda. Oh, my God. She's so good in this episode.
你们准备好听剧情概要了吗？我太爱这个了。就是这样。在这一集中，内德（Ned）追踪一个引人入胜的“杀猪盘”（网络交友欺诈）故事，结果却发现埃斯梅拉达（Esmeralda）是受害者之一。哦，可怜的埃斯梅拉达。哦，天哪。她在这一集里演得太棒了。
She is. The team scrambles to expose the scam while Esmeralda stubbornly insists that this guy is real. She keeps sending him money. Meanwhile, Detrick and Nicole are still figuring out their relationship status. And Mayor helps Ned with his online dating profile. They're very cutesy in this episode. They are. Mar and Ned.
确实。团队争分夺秒地揭露骗局，而埃斯梅拉达却固执地坚信这这家伙是真的。她一直在给他寄钱。与此同时，迪特里克（Detrick）和妮可（Nicole）仍在理清他们的恋爱关系状态。而梅尔（Mayor）帮内德弄了他的网上交友资料。他们在这一集里非常可爱。他们确实很可爱。梅尔和内德。
Yeah. Things are heating up. Yeah. There's a simmer happening. I'm going to say a simmer. Oh, I like that. Yeah? Yeah.
是的。事情正在升温。是的。正处于慢炖阶段。我要说是个慢炖阶段。哦，我喜欢这个。是吗？对啊。
That's a good description. Okay. I have my single fast fact for this episode. You never know if I'm going to do it or not. Oh, that's your new thing. That's my new thing. You might get one. You might not.
这是一个很好的描述。好吧。我准备了这一集的单集冷知识。你永远不知道我会不会做这个。哦，这是你的新把戏。这是我的新把戏。你可能会听到一个。也可能没有。
It's like that surprise gift. No. The surprise gift at Christmas, you know? Oh, yes. Like, I mean, my dad used to put little gifts in the tree. We never knew. Is there going to be something tucked away? in the tree? Yeah. It's the old like, oh, wait, do I see something there under the piano bench? There's
就像圣诞节的惊喜礼物一样，你知道的？哦，是的。我的意思是，我爸爸以前会在圣诞树上藏小礼物。我们从来都不知道。树上会不会藏着什么东西？
something you missed. Yeah. Yeah. Well, that's what this is today, everybody. This is your extra gift. You're going to love it. Are you ready? Yeah, you're really selling it. Well, I don't know. I found this interesting. This episode is one of the fan favorites of season one of the paper. Oh. There are like a gazillion Reddit threads that are dedicated to the paper and they all rave about this episode. According to seriesgraph.com, this is a website that just makes graphs of different TV series and their most popular episodes. This one got a rating of 7.8. That's very high. There's two other episodes rated that highly.
有些你漏掉的东西。好吧，这就是今天的节目，各位。这是你们的额外礼物。你们会喜欢的。准备好了吗？好吧，你真会推销。好吧，我不知道。我觉得这很有趣。这一集是《关于纸张》第一季中最受粉丝喜爱的剧集之一。哦。有无数个专门讨论《关于纸张》的Reddit帖子，他们都对这一集赞不绝口。根据 seriesgraph.com 的数据，这是一个专门制作不同电视剧及其最受欢迎剧集的图表的网站。这一集获得了7.8的高分。这非常高。还有其他两集也获得了这么高的评分。
And then the season finale, that one got an 8.6. That is the like everybody's like in love with the series finale. I can't wait. I know. I'm not there yet. Yes. Also on IMDB, this was the second highest rated episode of the 10. episodes of the paper. Congratulations, Moe, and Tasba. Yeah. Well, why don't we get to this breakdown?
然后是季终集，那一集得到了8.6分。那是大家对季终集喜爱有加的那一集。我等不及了。我知道。我还没看到那儿呢。是的。同样在IMDB上，这是《关于纸张》全部10集中评分第二高的剧集。恭喜莫和塔斯帕。是的。好吧，我们为什么不开始剖析呢？
I want you guys to know in the Peacock version, which is the extended version, there is a very funny cold open. It is not in the NBC broadcast version, but I want to give it a shout out. Basically, Esmeralda is in charge of planning Pride Month, like what they're doing for it. Are they going to have a float? Ken wants to have like rainbow toilet paper that. they're going to sell. Everyone pitches themes for what their float's going to be. It's very funny, cold open, but one of the reasons I wanted to bring it up is that Mo specifically talked about how obsessed she is with cold opens when we chatted with her. And I loved this perspective. We love a writer's perspective. She said because she's a stand-up comedian, she feels like cold
我想让大家知道，在孔雀（Peacock）版本（也就是加长版）中，有一个非常搞笑的冷开场。它不在NBC的电视广播版本中，但我一定要大声赞美它。基本上，埃斯梅拉达负责策划骄傲月（Pride Month）的活动，比如他们要为此做些什么。他们会有一辆花车吗？肯想弄些他们要售卖的彩虹卫生纸。大家都在推销他们花车主题的点子。这是一个非常搞笑的冷开场，但我想提起它的原因之一是，当我们和莫聊天时，她专门谈到了她对冷开场有多么痴迷。我太喜欢这个视角了。我们喜欢编剧的视角。她说因为她是个单口喜剧演员，她觉得冷开场就像是在做一个专场表演。就像你可以在你的剧集里讲一个单口相声笑话。并且她说过对于这一集，他们在剧本围读那天并没有写好冷开场。她不得不在5点45分做发型和化妆。所以我想她很快写了两个冷开场，然后格里格挑选了最终出现在剧里的那个。而且它甚至都没有改动。完全就是她写的那样。哦，天哪。你知道这勾起了什么回忆吗？
opens are like doing a set. It's like you get to do a stand-up joke as part of your episode. And she said for this particular episode, they did not have a cold open written on the day of the table read. And she had to be in hair and makeup at 545. So I guess she quickly wrote two cold opens and then Greg picked the one that ended up in the show. And it didn't even change. It just was the way she wrote it. Oh, my gosh. You know what that's bringing back memories of?
这勾起了保罗、明迪、BJ在早晨做发型和化妆时写作的回忆。是的。当他们一边做发型和化妆的时候。他们会进行创意推销、写作。我的意思是，我记得明迪写了她一半的书。
It's bringing back memories of Paul and Mindy and BJ and hair and makeup in the morning's writing. Yes. While they would be getting their hair and makeup done. They would be pitching, writing. I mean, I remember Mindy wrote half her book. In hair and makeup. Yeah, on her lap in the mornings at 5 a.m. She would have these like stretches of writing while she got her hair done.
在化妆椅上。是的，早上5点钟时大腿上放着电脑。她在做发型的时候会有这样一段段的写作时间。了不起的。了不起的编剧们。莫，我太喜欢那个故事了。如果你想看看那一幕，它就在加长版里。好吧，广播版的剧集是以托莱多警察局的阿诺德（Arnold）警探开场的。是的。他顺道来拜访。刚一开场，内德和阿诺德警探之间就有一段对话，当时他们正在对大办公室（bullpen）发表讲话。
Amazing. Amazing writers. Mo, I loved that story. And if you guys want to check out that scene, it's in the extended version. Well, the broadcast episode opens with Detective Arnold from the Toledo PD. Yeah. He's come by to visit. Right at the top, there's a couplet of dialogue between Ned and Detective Arnold as they addressed the bullpen.
这让我极度回忆起德怀特和迈克尔的画面。是的。字面意思上，内德说警探一直在向我通报一件非常重要的公共安全事务。他把我任命为某种副警长。而阿诺德警探说：不，不是副警长。然后内德说：但我被授衔了。阿诺德警探说：不，你没有。然后内德说：但我被简报过了。
And it gave me such Dwight Michael flashbacks. Yes. I mean, literally, Ned says the detective has been briefing me about a very important public safety matter. He's made me kind of a deputy. And Detective Arnold says, nope, not a deputy. And Ned's like, but I have been deputized. And Detective Arnold's like, no, you have not. And Ned's like, but I have been briefed.
然后警探说：好吧。但这难道不就像德怀特想当副警长和志愿警长一样吗？我觉得非常像。最后警探会向大家宣布，网上有一个专挑女性下手的“杀猪盘”骗子。而且这个场景的背景里有一些很棒的细节，女士。我记下来了一些。好吧，54秒。
And the detective is like, sure. But isn't that so like Dwight wanting to be like the deputy sheriff and the volunteer sheriff? I think very much. Well, ultimately the detective is going to share with everyone that there is a catfisher, praying on women online. And there's some great details in the background of this scene, lady. I wrote down a few. Okay, 54 seconds.
你看到那两个一直坐在办公桌前的索蒂斯（Softies）员工了吗？他们就在特拉维斯（Travis）身后。他们就坐在那儿，啪啪啪地打字。没有。我的意思是，太棒了。我太想念他们了。这让我想起了前几季背景里的德文（Devin）和克里德（Creed）。你注意到埃斯梅拉达拿着一个悠悠球吗？一个红色的悠悠球。1分08秒。跟她的裙子很配。这到底是为什么？
Did you see the two softy employees who are sitting at their desk the whole time? They're right behind Travis. And they're just there, typing away. No. I mean, amazing. I miss them. It reminded me of like Devin and Creed in the background of those early seasons. Did you notice that Esmeralda is holding a yo-yo? A red yo-yo. One minute, eight seconds. It matches her dress. What is that about?
你看到贴在墙上梅尔身后的那张纸了吗？那是一张纸，上面写着“五个W”（新闻五要素）。是的，我看到了。还有1分09秒。向那个半吊子的排插致敬，它有点挂在柱子上，平衡地搭在隔断的一部分上，还拖着电线。看起来太山寨了。我当时就觉得，我不知道。我太喜欢这个了。好吧，我们要向饰演阿诺德警探的艾萨克·斯蒂芬·蒙哥马利（Isaac Stephen Montgomery）致敬。你可能在《芝加哥烈焰》、《海军罪案调查处》以及瑞恩·高斯林主演的电影《灰影人》中看过他。他非常搞笑。他面无表情地演。真的很好。但我对这一整场戏有一个评论。
Did you see the piece of paper taped behind mayor that's on the wall? It's a piece of paper and it says the five Ws. Yes, I did see that. And then also one minute, 21 seconds. Shout out to the half-assed power strip that's kind of hanging off the column, balancing on part of the partition with wires coming out of it. It looks so janky. I just was like, I don't know. I love that. Well, let's give a shout out to Isaac Stephen Montgomery, who played Detective Arnold. You might have seen him in Chicago Fire, NCIS, and the movie The Grey Man starring Ryan Gosling. He's very funny. He plays it straight. It's really good. But I do have one comment about this
我写道，这是一场完全可以用一封电子邮件代替的会议。这费了好大劲啊。他亲自跑下来只为了告诉他们两句话的信息。好吧，内德非常兴奋。他是亲自来的。他现在要把所有人召集到会议室里，还借用了索蒂斯公司的白板。我知道。特拉维斯就像是：金伯利可不会喜欢那样的。我有一个来自新泽西州蒙特克莱尔的切斯卡·C（Cheska C）提供的背景彩蛋。切斯卡写信说：“我兴奋得有点过头了，因为我通常绝对不会注意到这种细节，但我正在看《办公室》，这是我第一次注意到我认为是一个连续性错误。我从来没有对一个错误这么兴奋过，感叹号！”这些细节抓起来确实很有趣。我知道。在内德在白板上写关于“杀猪盘”阴谋的那个场景中，DM（社交账号缩写）下面的方框最初写的是：渴望当爸爸（Desperate for a Daddy）。
whole scene. I wrote, this was a meeting that could have been an email. This is a lot of effort. He came down to tell them like two sentences of information. Well, Ned is very excited. He came in person. He's now going to gather everyone in the conference room and he's borrowed the whiteboard from Softies. I know. Travis is like Kimberly is not going to like that. I have a background catch from Cheska C in Montclair, New Jersey. Cheska wrote in and said, I am way too excited because I generally never catch stuff like this, but I'm watching the paper for the first time
然后有那么一会儿，同一个方块在同一个位置写的是：叫我爸爸（call me daddy）。然后它又变回了：渴望当爸爸。哇。这是一个很好的背景彩蛋。真的很好的背景彩蛋。是的，切斯卡说后来，当白板被推出来时，我们待会儿会说到。它又变回了“渴望当爸爸”。太棒的彩蛋了。好吧，内德要解释了，这个骗局是这样运作的。交友软件上有一个人，自称来自托莱多，但他目前驻扎在德国。
and I just saw what I believe to be a continuity error. I've never been so excited about an error, exclamation point. They really are fun to catch. I know. During the scene where Ned is writing about the catfish scheme on the whiteboard, the box under DM's originally reads, Desperate for a Daddy.
是的。他们在军队服役，正为买不起感恩节回家的机票而发愁。
Then at one point, the same square in the same location reads, call me daddy. It then changes back to desperate for a daddy. Wow. That's a good background catch. Really good background catch. Yeah, Cheska said later, when the whiteboard is wheeled out, we'll get to it. It has gone back to desperate for a daddy. Great catch. Well, Ned is going to explain, here's how the scheme works. There is somebody on these dating apps who claims to be from Toledo, but they are currently stationed in Germany. Yeah. They are in the military. and they're struggling to afford to fly home for Thanksgiving.
是的，他们在这个叫拉奇（latch）的交友软件上勾搭人。内德对这个人的解释越多，镜头开始推向埃斯梅拉达，你一眼就能看出她正在被“杀猪盘”诈骗。她的演技太好了。那种猛然意识到的表情涌上心头，而且还有一个细节，我太喜欢了，她手里拿着一杯水，杯子上面全都被她的红唇膏印覆盖了。好吧，内德列出了骗子用来称呼他目标的名字。
Yeah, they're hitting up people on this dating app called latch. The more Ned explains this person, the camera starts to push in on Esmeralda, and you can just tell that she's getting catfished. Her acting is so good. The realization that just washes over her, and there is also this little detail, and I loved it so much, she's holding a glass of water, and it is just covered in her red lipstick stains. Well, Ned is going to list the names that the catfisher uses on his marks.
我太喜欢这个名单了。我太喜欢他念这份名单的语气了。我太喜欢这份名单了。我把它写下来了。甜心（Sweet cheeks）、宝贝（Baby babe）、饼干公主（Cookie princess）、宝贝宝贝（Baby baby）、宝宝（Baby）和宝贝（Babe），有时甚至只是宝贝（Baby）。这些是，这些是你会从骗子那里得到的甜言蜜语。没错。我知道我们还没走多远，
I loved this list so much. I loved his delivery of the list. I loved the list. I wrote it down. Sweet cheeks, baby babe, cookie princess, baby baby, baby, and babe, and sometimes just baby. These are the, this is the sweet talk you're going to get from the catfisher. Yep. I know we haven't gotten very far.
但我已经谷歌了更多。什么？现在又怎么了？我们是不是得说出我们平时称呼别人的亲昵称呼了？没有。我们可能得把这一集标为“MA”级。MA？仅限成年观众（Mature audience only）？对。如果你带着孩子在听，你可能想快进一下。我卡在“饼干公主”上了。我卡在“饼干公主”上了。然后我想，我觉得“饼干”是阴道的俚语。我的意思是，安吉拉对德怀特说：没有饼干（no cookie）。对，它是。它是俚语。意思是骚屄。
far, but I did more Googling already. What? What now? Are we going to have to say our affectionate names we call people? No. We might have to give this one an MA. M.A. Mature audience only? Yeah. If you're listening with your kids, you might want to fast forward. I got stuck on cookie princess. I got stuck on cookie princess. And then I thought, I think cookie is slang for vagina. I mean, Angela says to Dwight, no cookie. Yeah, it is. It is slang. It means pussie.
所以，顺便说一句，我在《办公室》里说那句台词时，我以为它的意思是“胡闹”。没有胡闹。我没意识到我当时说的是“没有骚屄”。对，我想是的。然后我就陷入了一个深渊。食物竟然是性暗示非常常见的俚语。如果你想听，我有一个清单。我的意思是，我对这个并不感到惊讶。
So, by the way, when I said that line on the office, I thought it meant hanky-panky. No hanky-panky. I didn't realize I was saying no pussie. Yeah, I think so. And I went down a rabbit hole. Food is a really common slang for sexual innuendo. And I have a list if you want it. I mean, I'm not surprised by that.
没有。你的清单是什么？好吧。指代阴道的其他词有：桃子（peach）、松饼（muffin）和牡蛎（oyster）。好吧。指代阴茎的有：茄子（eggplant）、香肠（sausage）、泡菜（pickle）和黄瓜（cucumber）。我以为桃子是指屁股。萨姆？
No. What's your list? Okay. Other terms for vagina are peach, muffin, and oyster. Okay. For penis, it's eggplant, sausage, pickle, and cucumber. I thought peach was a butt. Sam?
桃子是屁股吗？桃子是屁股还是桃子？你的甜桃子？难道你不吃甜桃子吗？我主要听说桃子是指屁股。哦。嗯哼。好吧。
Is peach a butt? Is peach a butt or peach? Your sweet peach? Don't you eat a sweet peach? I've primarily heard Peach be a butt. Oh. Mm-hmm. Okay.
好吧。哇。这就是他们在那个电影里吃桃子的原因吗？什么电影？蒂莫西·柴勒梅德演的，他在里面吃，那绝对是我这辈子见过的最性感的吃桃子场景。我听说过这个，但我不知道是什么电影。什么电影？《请以你的名字呼唤我》。他们在意大利。他们在乡间骑自行车。这是一个爱情故事，
Okay. Wow. Is that why they eat the peach in that movie? Yeah. What movie? Timothy Shalame, where he eats the, it's literally the sexiest peach eating I've ever seen in my life. I've heard of this thing, but I don't know the movie. What's the movie? Call me by your name. They're in Italy. There's bicycling in the countryside. It's a love story,
他吃了一个桃子。特别性感。哦，天哪。完全是黄色废料。去看吧。好吧，这个我可不知道。热狗是阴茎的代名词。好吧。但你知道热狗加面包（hot dog in a bun）是什么意思吗？是不是夹在屁股缝里的热狗？不对。好吧，那是，我以为面包就像是，不对。什么？加面包的意思是未割包皮的。为什么？它是，嗯，它还在面包里。哦，天哪。好吧，好吧。哦，不。我不知道，这可能是我不需要知道的信息。好吧。这是一个我没听过的词。鱼市（Fish Market）。你知道什么是鱼市吗？
and he eats this peach. It is particularly sexy. Oh my gosh. Total smut. Watch it. Okay. Now, I did not know this one. Hot dog is like term for a penis. Okay. But do you know what hot dog? dog in a bun means. Is it a hot dog wedge between butt cheeks? Nope. Well, that was, I thought a bun is like, No. What? In a bun means uncircumcised. Why? It's, well, it's still in its bun. Oh, God. Yeah, all right. Oh, no. I don't, this might be information I don't need to know. Okay. Here's a term I had not heard. Fish Market. Do you know what a fish market is?
那是19世纪对妓院的称呼。好吧。还有“抽香肠”（flog the sausage），“甩萨拉米”（slam the salami）。手淫？是的。是的。太棒了。你知道吗？
It's a 19th century term for a brothel. Okay. The terms flog the sausage, slam the salami. Masturbating? Yes. Yes. Great job. Do you know what?
我迫不及待想写信告诉妈妈了。你知道什么是带穗玉米（corn on the cob）吗？不知道。就是你身上还穿着部分或全部衣服时进行性行为。什么？不对。我觉得这是一个英国词。谁说的？
I can't wait to write home and tell mom. Do you know what corn on the cob is? No. It's having sex while you're still partially or fully dressed. What? No. I think it's a British term. Who says?
有人这么说。是的，这里面很多听起来像是编造的。谁说我刚……互联网。我……什么互联网？你在上网浏览什么部分？我跟一个男的勾搭了。
That says that. Yeah, a lot of these seem made up. Who says I just got... The internet. I... What internet? What part of the internet are you on? I hooked up with a guy.
他是个热狗，然后我们做了带穗玉米的事。是的，你可以这么说。我会知道他是割过包皮的，而你们穿着衣服做了爱。我是割过包皮的。不，不。热狗加面包意思是没割包皮的。它还在面包里。哦，对，对，对。
He was a hot dog and we did the little corn on the cob. Yes, you could say that. I would know that he was circumcised and you had sex with your clothes on. I'm circumcised. No, no. Hot dog in a bun means uncircised. It's still in the bun. Oh, right, right, right.
就只是个热狗。好吧。我吃了一个带面包的热狗，还有一些……在我们吃带穗玉米的时候。是的。听起来很棒。干净利落的方式。好吧，各位，你们可以重新开始带着孩子一起听了。埃斯梅拉达要离开这个会议室，走进她的办公室并关上门。她冲了出去。是的。每个人都注意到了。所有人都知道她被“杀猪盘”骗了。是的。妮可和阿达洛拉对此感到非常高兴。
Just a hot dog. Okay. I had a hot dog with a bun and some while while we were corn on. the cob. Yes. Sounds great. Clean way. Well, everyone, you can start listening with your kids again. Esmerelda is going to leave this meeting and go in her office and shut her door. She rushes out. Yeah. And everybody clocks it. Everyone knows that she's being catfished. Yeah. Nicole and Adalola are incredibly happy about
他们受够了埃斯梅拉达，他们幸灾乐祸。是的。妮可有一个访谈（talking head），在里面她细数了她跟埃斯梅拉达积怨已久的这笔账。好吧，内德意识到“哦天哪，我们居然有内应遭遇了杀猪盘骗子”时，他兴奋极了。我们得让她讲出她的故事。他想把它做成一个六部分的系列报道。他认为这可能会得奖。他对自己能写出这篇可能轰动新闻的文章感到非常兴奋。
this. They are sick and tired of Esmeralda, and they're delighted. Yeah. Nicole has a talking head where she lists off this beef she's had with Esmeralda for a long time. Well, Ned is so excited when he realizes, oh my gosh, we have someone on the inside who has dealt with the catfisher. We got to get her to tell her story. He wants it to be a six-part series. He thinks it could be award-winning. He's very excited about this possible news-breaking article that he can write.
金伯利现在进来了。她气坏了，因为他们占用了她的白板，她要把它他妈的拉走。是的，由编剧莫·韦尔奇饰演的金伯利。我对她的毛衣着迷了。你注意到在5分29秒时，她穿着这件，像是黑色的短袖，左肩膀上有一只灰色的小绵羊吗？你注意到这个了吗？
Kimberly now is going to come in. She's pissed off because they have her why. whiteboard, and she's going to pull it the F out. Yes, Kimberly, played by writer Mo Welch. I got very obsessed with her sweater. Did you notice at five minutes, 29 seconds, she's wearing this, like, black short sleeve, and there's a small little gray sheep on her left shoulder. Did you clock that?
我不得不截了个图。这是一个牌子吗？我很想知道。我谷歌了“哪里能买到这件有一只绵羊的衬衫”？你买不到。你会买到很多绵羊。你会买到一只黑羊。
I had to take a screen grab of it. Is it a brand? I wanted to know. I Googled where can I buy this shirt with one sheep? You can't. You get lots of sheep. You get a black sheep. no one gray sheep.
没有灰色绵羊。所以我联系了《关于纸张》的服装设计师。哦！凯德琳·菲利克斯·哈格（Kathleen Felix Hager）。她的简历太厉害了。她担任过《绝望写手》（Hacks）、《副总统》（Veep）、《太空部队》（Space Force）、《嗜血法医》（Dexter）等许多其他节目的服装设计。我说：“凯德琳，你能跟我讲讲这件灰色小绵羊T恤吗？”她说：“首先，我想说，格里格和迈克尔真的很让我放飞自我去设计角色，而且演员阵容非常可爱，合作起来太棒了。”
So I reached out to the costume designer for the paper. Oh! Kathleen Felix Hager. Her resume is so impressive. She has done the costume design for hacks, VEP, Space Force, Dexter, so many other shows. And I said, Kathleen, can you please tell me about this little gray sheep t-shirt? And she said, first of all, I want to share that Greg and Michael really let me have fun with the characters and the cast is so lovely. and amazing to work with.
至于那件绵羊毛衣，那只绵羊实际上是索蒂斯公司的标志。哦，所以她必须设计那个。她为所有的索蒂斯员工制作了各种运动衫和Polo衫，还专门为金伯利制作了一件紫色的连体裤，上面绣着
As far as the sheep sweater, that sheep is actually the logo for the Softies Company. Oh, so she had to design that. She made various sweatshirts and polos for all the Softies employees and a special purple jumpsuit just for Kimberly to wear
绵羊标志。然后我就说：“好吧，凯德琳，既然你有空，你能跟我聊聊其他角色吗？他们都有非常具体的造型。”例如，梅尔有很多开衫。然后，当然还有，
with the sheep logo embroidered on it. And then I was like, well, Kathleen, while I have you, can you share with me about any of the other characters? They have such specific looks. For example, Mayor has all these cardigans. And then, of course,
埃斯梅拉达，对吧？是的，带着她的蛇形皮带。我知道。所以她说，对于梅尔，她真的倾向于那个角色的军事背景，她有一种假小子（tomboyish）的气质。她说那些毛衣全都是复古的，是转售淘来的。她希望
Esmeralda, right? Yeah, with her snake belt. I know. So she said for mayor, she really leaned into that character's military background, and she has this tomboyish vibe. She said the sweaters are all vintage, our resale finds. She wanted
她的所有造型都让人感觉真实而生活化。确实如此。是不是很棒？是的。她写道：“埃斯梅拉达，感叹号！哇，我能说什么呢？萨布丽娜（Sabrina）是一股能量旋风，我和她一起合作设计埃斯梅拉达穿的那些创意造型，玩得太开心了。”她说埃斯梅拉达有她自己独特的品味和风格，但总有一些地方有点不对劲或者说出格，而且是以一种绝妙的方式。
all of her looks to feel really lived in and real. They do. Isn't that great? Yeah. She wrote, Esmeralda exclamation point, wow, what can I say? Sabrina is a whirlwind of energy, and I had so much fun collaborating with her on the creative looks as Marelda wears. She said Esmeralda has a taste and style of her own, but there is always something a bit off our wrong in a wonderful way.
她的所有造型都让人感觉非常真实、接地气。确实如此。不是很棒吗？是的。她写道：“埃斯梅拉达！哇，我能说什么呢？萨布丽娜就像一阵充满活力的旋风，我和她一起合作马雷尔达穿着的那些创意造型时玩得太开心了。”她说：“埃斯梅拉达有她自己的品味和风格，但总有一种奇妙的、略显不对劲或错误的感觉。”
I felt like in this episode it was that butterfly hair clip. Really? Yes, it was just odd, in the right way. That red dress is gorgeous. And she wears this gold belt around it, even though it goes over the zipper in the back. Yes. I did ask her about the belts, and she said the belts were all costume house finds and sourced from vintage and resale a lot of the real real online. Do you know this, the real real real? Of course the real real. I know. I buy things from the real real all the time. And then she said, I also want to share about Ned. Donal is super collaborative and he loved all the textures and subtle patterns we mixed and matched. Did you notice his color palette? It's intentional. Is it like some olive greens and stuff? She said, we stayed in the blue,
我觉得在这一集里，就是那个蝴蝶发夹。真的吗？对，它就是有一种恰到好处的古怪。那条红裙子太惊艳了。而且她还在外面系了一条金腰带，哪怕那腰带正好压在背后的拉链上。没错。我确实问过她关于腰带的事，她说这些腰带都是从服装间里淘来的，很多都是复古货和二手货，还有很多来自 The RealReal 线上平台。你知道这个吗，The RealReal？当然知道 The RealReal。我知道。我经常在 The RealReal 上买东西。然后她说，我还想分享一下关于内德的事。多纳尔超级有合作精神，他特别喜欢我们混搭的各种质感和低调的图案。你注意到他的色调了吗？那是刻意安排的。是不是有点像橄榄绿之类的？她说，我们所有的造型都保持在蓝色、
gray and green color palette for all of his looks. Yeah. And then I went digging and I found this great article on femstella.com, and it's all the outfits and where you can get them all online. It's really a great article. I'll share it. Oh, great. Well, next up, Ned is going to go in to check on Esmeralda.
灰色和绿色的色调范围内。对。然后我去深挖了一下，在 femstella.com 上找到了一篇很棒的文章，里面列出了所有的穿搭以及你可以在哪里网购到它们。这真的是一篇很棒的文章。我会分享出来的。哦，太棒了。那么接下来，内德要去看看埃斯梅拉达。
He says, I noticed you had a very strong reaction to the catfish story. Oh, my gosh. Esmeralda has the best response. She always has such great one-liners. She said, I react strongly to everything. Life is strong, and I'm a strong woman. I know. Ned is kind of like trying to get her to talk about this new online love that she has and finds out his name.
他说，我注意到你对那个网恋骗局的故事反应非常强烈。哦，天哪。埃斯梅拉达的回应绝了。她总是能说出这么棒的妙语。她说，我对什么都反应强烈。生活很强烈，而我是一个坚强的女人。我懂。内德有点像是在试图让她聊聊她那个新的网上恋情，并打听对方的名字。
His name is Jarsen. I mean, it's a common American name. Very common. Jesus. Jason and Jared combined. I did want to point out at 5 minutes, 49 seconds, there is a plant that is dying on Esmeralda's death. There is. Yes.
他的名字叫贾森（Jarsen）。我的意思是，这是一个很常见的美国名字。非常常见。天哪。是杰森（Jason）和贾里德（Jared）的结合体。我确实想指出，在 5 分钟 49 秒的时候，埃斯梅拉达的办公桌上有一株正在枯死的植物。确实有。是的。
That's pretty amazing. By the way, do you know why it's called catfishing? I don't. Is this another weird term? No. So this thing where you go online and you end up being scammed by someone who's pretending to be somebody they're not, it ended up being called catfishing because there was a 2010 documentary called Catfish.
这挺神奇的。顺便说一句，你知道为什么它叫“网恋诈骗”（catfishing）吗？我不知道。这是另一个奇怪的术语吗？不是的。所以，这种你在网上交友，结果却被一个假冒他人身份的骗子诈骗的事情，之所以被称为 catfishing，是因为 2010 年有一部名为《鲶鱼》（Catfish）的纪录片。
I saw Catfish. Yeah. It was so good. It's so good. Like, watch this documentary. It's incredible. So in this documentary, they tell this story of how fishermen keep cod active in their tanks after they've been caught by throwing a catfish in there. Because what they were finding was like, if you just try to transport the cod in a barrel or whatever you transport them in, I don't know.
我看过《鲶鱼》。对。真的太棒了。太棒了。总之去看这部纪录片吧。简直不可思议。所以在纪录片里，他们讲了这样一个故事：渔夫们把鳕鱼捕捞上来后，会往鱼槽里扔一条鲶鱼，以此来让鳕鱼保持活跃。因为他们发现，如果你只是试着把鳕鱼装在木桶里运输，或者随便什么运输工具里，我不知道。
In my mind, it's a wooden barrel like ye olden days. They're just lazy. And then they just sort of, you know, they don't do anything. And then they don't taste as good. But if you throw a dye or something? Does the catfish keep them active? No, they just get mushy. They get like mushy.
在我的想象中，就像老电影里那种木桶。它们太懒了。然后它们就，你知道的，什么也不做。接着它们的肉就不好吃了。但是如果你扔进去一条什么鱼？鲶鱼能让它们保持活跃吗？不，它们的肉会变得软绵绵的。会变得像浆糊一样。
But if you throw a catfish in the barrel, it keeps them swimming around and active and like alert. And then when they get to shore, the cod is going to taste better. Huh. So this guy says, listen, I think this person's a little bit like a catfish. They're just keeping life interesting. It's sort of like didn't like, I don't know, is it so bad to be a catfish in a bunch of cod? And so that's where the term for the movie came from.
但如果你往木桶里扔一条鲶鱼，它就会让鳕鱼不停地游动，保持活跃和警惕。然后等它们到达岸边时，鳕鱼的肉质就会更好。哈。所以这个家伙就说，听着，我觉得这个人有点像鲶鱼。他们只是让生活变得有趣。这有点像是，难道，我不知道，在一堆鳕鱼里当一条鲶鱼真的很糟糕吗？所以这就是电影片名的由来。
And then it, like, blew up from there. Yeah, it is a great documentary. It's kind of making me want to watch it again. I know it made me want to watch it again, too. Well, back in the conference room, the staff are now taking bets on how much money as Marilda has been sending Jarsen. They're really kind of tickled by all this. Also, they've decided to all make online dating apps as well on this latch site so they can try
然后它就像病毒一样火爆全网。对，这真是一部很棒的纪录片。这让我有点想再看一遍了。我知道，这也让我想再看一遍。好了，镜头回到会议室里，员工们现在正开盘下注，猜埃斯梅拉达到底给贾森汇了多少钱。他们真的觉得这一切挺逗的。而且，他们还决定都在这个 Latch 网站上注册网恋应用，这样他们就可以试着
to find Jarsin on their own. Yeah, they're hoping to get catfished so they can write their story. So Mare asks, does anybody already have a latch profile? Yeah. A few people raise their hands, including Nicole. Yeah. And Detrick is kind of like, wait, what? Yeah.
靠自己找到贾森了。对，他们希望自己也能被网恋诈骗，这样他们就能把自己的故事写出来了。所以梅尔就问，有没有人已经有 Latch 个人资料了？对。有几个人举了手，包括妮可。对。然后德特里克就一副“等等，什么？”的表情。对。
He has a talking head where he's like, me and Nicole have hung out a few times in this last week. And I deleted my app after the first hangout. Yeah. When he has his talking head, they flash back to the two of them making out. They're outside of the Buckeye Ball Bar and Grill. I zoomed in. Can we just talk about this makeout for a second? Well, we talked about it last week.
他有一个面对镜头的独白，里面说：我和妮可在过去这一周里一起出去过好几次。我在第一次约会后就把应用给删了。对。当他进行独白时，画面闪回到他们两个人在热吻。他们就在巴克艾球杆酒吧烧烤店（Buckeye Ball Bar and Grill）外面。我放大画面了。我们能聊聊这个吻吗？好吧，我们上周已经聊过了。
I know, but now we see more of it. Okay. He's sitting on a stool. She's standing as a makeout grabs his leg and wraps it around her. Yeah. Things are heating up there is all I'm saying. I don't know what you call that. It's not quite the corn cob, but it's pretty spicy.
我知道，但现在我们看到了更多画面。好吧。他坐在高脚凳上。她站着接吻，然后一把抓住他的腿，把它盘在自己腰上。对。我想说的是，事情在那里开始升温了。我不知道你怎么称呼那个。虽然不太像玉米棒，但确实挺火辣的。
Yeah. I mean, this makeout has really, you have homed in on this. You talked about it a lot last week. Well, I'm sorry, but that's the first. first time they kiss and she grabs his leg and wraps it around? I know. They are very close to a corn on the cob. They are.
对。我的意思是，这个吻真的，你对这个太关注了。你上周聊了好多。好吧，我很抱歉，但这可是他们第一次接吻，而她竟然抓住他的腿并把它盘在身上？我知道。他们离玉米棒子只有一步之遥了。确实。
They really are. I'm sorry if that is sort of like jaw dropping to me. I'm like, dang. Yeah. I mean, I guess I'm thinking back. Like, has my first kiss ever led to that sort of thing so quickly? I don't know. I think it's a bold move.
真的太像了。如果这对我来说有点像惊掉下巴的话，我很抱歉。我当时就想，天哪。对。我的意思是，我在回想。比如，我的初吻曾经这么快就发展到那种程度吗？我不知道。我觉得这真是个大胆的举动。
Okay. The first time you kiss someone, you grab their legs. off a bar stool and wrap it around you. All right. Anyway. Fair enough. Fair enough. Well, this is where Nicole is going to say, like, why don't you have a latch profile?
好吧。你第一次和某人接吻，就把他们的腿从酒吧高脚凳上拽下来盘在自己身上。好吧。总之。不过也对。不过也对。好吧，就在这里，妮可打算说，比如，你为什么没有 Latch 个人资料？
And he's like, well, I deleted it. And she's like reactivated. Yeah. And then she says in a talking head, you know, we're having fun, but he's still in my phone as, quote, Dettrick work. Yeah. And Dettrick looks hurt by this, by the way. He looks bummed out.
而他就说，哦，我把它删了。然后她说重新激活它。对。然后她在独白里说，你知道的，我们玩得很开心，但他依然在我手机里被备注为“工作狂德特里克”，带引号的。对。顺便说一句，德特里克看起来被这事伤到了。他看起来很沮丧。
Can I say something? Say it. I know it. I know what you're going to say. What is he seeing her? She's not very nice to him. No. She's not. And he seems like a catch. He's a really nice guy. Yes. And he looks like he's ready to be. In vested. He wins her a bird. I mean, he just seems like he is open to intimacy, to commitment, to monogamy. I don't know. Those are the things I was looking for when I was Dating? Nicole might just want the leg wrap. She kind of does. I think that's where she's at. But he's dazzled by her. I know. I mean, and that happens, right? Like, sometimes, like, if you're steady and kind of like a homebody, you get into a little bit of wild. Maybe that's what's
我能说句话吗？说吧。我知道。我知道你要说什么。他到底看上她哪一点了？她对他一点都不好。没错。她真的不好。而且他看起来是个不错的对象。他是个超级大好人。对。而且他看起来已经准备好了。投入。他还给她赢了一只鸟。我的意思是，他看起来就是那种对亲密关系、对承诺、对一夫一妻制持开放态度的人。我不知道。这些正是我以前在找的……寻找伴侣时看重的特质？妮可可能只是想要个盘腿杀。她差不多就是这样。我觉得这就是她的现状。但他被她迷住了。我知道。我的意思是，这种事时有发生，对吧？比如，有时，如果你生活稳定又有点像个宅男，你就会想体验一点点疯狂。也许这就是
happening here. Yeah. Okay. I was trying to think of a term for it, but I could come up with one. A food term? Yeah. Maybe you like a little pretzel. A little popcorn. You know, it's popping. Oh, yeah. Yeah. He's more of a, I don't know, what's comforting? Soup. He's the soup and she's the popcorn.
这里正在发生的事情。对。好吧。我一直在试图想一个词来形容它，但我之前没想出来。食物类的词？对。也许你喜欢一点小饼干。一点爆米花。你知道的，这很火爆。哦，对。对。他更像是一个，我不知道，什么东西让人觉得有安全感？汤。他是汤，而她是爆米花。
They don't quite mix. They really don't, do they? I don't know. Some chef has put popcorn in soup before and it's been wonderful, but, you know, it's rare. Ned sees the betting board and he thinks that Esmeralda is probably out at least 4,000. 4,200 if there's nudes. Well, we know there's nudes because she throws him out of her office and she says, I need to send Jarsen's nudes. Get out of here.
他们两个不太搭。真的不太搭，对吧？我不知道。有些厨师曾经把爆米花放进汤里，味道还挺棒的，但是，你知道的，这很罕见。内德看到了赌博记分板，他觉得埃斯梅拉达至少花出去了 4,000 美元。如果有裸照的话就是 4,200 美元。好吧，我们知道有裸照，因为她把内德赶出了办公室，并且说：我需要发贾森的裸照。滚出去。
I know. Well, lady, why don't we take a break? And then when we come back, we are going to discuss how Esmeralda gets a video from Jarsen and plays it for the group. Oh, yeah. It's clearly a cameo. So we are back. Ned has brought Esmeralda a cup of tea. And this is one of my favorite lines in the whole episode.
我知道。好吧，各位，我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来后，我们将讨论埃斯梅拉达是如何收到贾森发来的一段视频，并把它放给小组看的。哦，对。这明显是一个卡梅奥（Cameo）明星祝福视频。好了，我们回来了。内德给埃斯梅拉达泡了一杯茶。这是整集里我最喜欢的台词之一。
I loved it so much. Esmeralda says, thank you. Such a nice idea for someone that drinks only coffee. I asked Mo what it was like working with Sabrina, and she said episode five couldn't happen without a powerful comedic powerhouse like Sabrina. She went on to share that at the end of the episode, there's this dance sequence that Sabrina does. It's in the peacock version.
我太喜欢了。埃斯梅拉达说：谢谢。这对于一个只喝咖啡的人来说真是个好主意。我问过莫（Mo）和萨布丽娜（Sabrina）合作是什么感觉，她说如果没有像萨布丽娜这样强大的喜剧大咖，第五集根本不可能拍成。她接着分享说，在这一集的结尾，有一个萨布丽娜跳舞的桥段。那是孔雀（Peacock）流媒体版本里的。
She's like, if you haven't seen it, go watch it. They love writing for her. She's so game and up for everything. The character of Esmeralda is very divisive on the Reddit threads. People either love her or hate her. Oh, yeah. Like, it's very divisive. My brain cannot comprehend not loving her.
她当时说，如果你还没看过，快去看看。他们特别喜欢为她写剧本。她超级配合，对什么都来者不拒。埃斯梅拉达这个角色在红迪网（Reddit）的讨论串上两极分化非常严重。人们要么极度喜欢她，要么极其讨厌她。哦，对。真的，两极分化太严重了。我的大脑无法理解怎么会有人不喜欢她。
She is such a supreme comedic talent. Also, English is not her first language. And yet, the way she delivers lines, I can't even wrap my head around it. The way she throws things away, the way she will single out a certain word that creates a rhythm. It's like a comedy marvel to me. And when we met her, I just could not get enough of her. Yes. She shared with us, and we have this interview.
她有着无与伦比的喜剧天赋。而且，英语不是她的母语。然而她抛出台词的方式，我简直无法想象。她那种漫不经心的语气，她对某个特定词汇的挑剔，从而营造出一种节奏感。对我来说，这简直是个喜剧奇迹。当我们见到她时，我简直对她爱不释手。对。她和我们分享了，我们有这样一个采访。
We played on the podcast just about her journey to being here. And she's just such a fascinating person. And she brings all of that richness and vibrancy to Esmeralda. She's a true artist. Esmeralda is going to just charge out into the bullpen and loudly confront everyone that's been laughing about her. She knows that they're talking behind her back. And she shows them a photo of Jarstead. Look, he's real.
我们在播客里播出了这段采访，讲的就是她一路走到这里的历程。她真的是一个极其迷人的人。她为埃斯梅拉达带来了所有的丰富性和活力。她是一位真正的艺术家。埃斯梅拉达随后冲进了办公区，大声质问所有一直在嘲笑她的人。她知道他们在背后议论她。然后她给他们看了一张贾森的照片。看，他是真的。
Here he is. And it's Josh Holloway. Yes. From Lost. It's a picture of Josh Holloway holding a picture of Esmeralda. And this is the proof. And it's clearly been Photoshopped. And it's Josh Holloway.
他在这儿。那是乔什·哈洛韦（Josh Holloway）。对。来自《迷失》（Lost）。那是乔什·哈洛韦拿着一张埃斯梅拉达照片的照片。这就是证据。而且这很明显是被 P 过图的。这就是乔什·哈洛韦。
Oscar's like, he lives in Hawaii. Yes. He's from Lost. Lady, do you know about the woman who believed she was communicating? with Brad Pitt? Did you see these articles? A French woman? Oh, lady, lady.
奥斯卡说：他住在夏威夷。对。他来自《迷失》。各位，你们知道那个相信自己正在与布拉德·皮特交流的女性吗？你们看过这些文章吗？一个法国女人？哦，天哪，天哪。
She sent Brad Pitt, who she thought was Brad Pitt over $850,000. No. Yes. No. Yes. That's horrible. Here's how it went down. She said it started with somebody posing as Brad Pitt's mom.
她给布拉德·皮特——她以为那是布拉德·皮特的人——汇了超过 85 万美元。不会吧。是真的。不会吧。是真的。这太可怕了。事情是这样的。她说，这一切始于一个冒充布拉德·皮特妈妈的人。
So fake Brad Pitt's mom reached out to her on social media and said, My son could really use a woman like you. Wow. And then she said, my son is Brad Pitt. Then she put the two of them in touch. So fake Brad Pitt's mom puts this woman in touch with fake Brad Pitt, probably the same person, right? And she starts communicating with this person for like 18 months.
所以假布拉德·皮特的妈妈在社交媒体上联系了她说：我儿子真的很需要一个像你这样的女性。哇。然后她说，我儿子是布拉德·皮特。接着她把这两人牵线搭桥了。所以假布拉德·皮特的妈妈把这个女人介绍给了假布拉德·皮特，很可能是同一个人，对吧？然后她开始和这个人交流了大约 18 个月。
She got poems. Eventually, he sent her a marriage proposal. Did he speak French? This is a really good question. I think they were letters that I don't think I didn't get that there was any ever like audio. But still, in this scenario, Brad Pitt is proficient in French. There's a great AI photo that goes along with this too. This is what I was going to get to.
她收到了情诗。最终，他向她求婚了。他说法语吗？这是一个非常好的问题。我想那些都是信件，我不觉得……我不觉得这其中有过任何音频。不过，即便在这种设定下，布拉德·皮特也是个精通法语的人。这里还有一张很棒的 AI 生成的照片与之配套。这就是我要说的。
Okay. No, no, don't be sorry, Sam. Yes. So here's how he first gets money out of her. He says, I want to send you a very expensive purse to show my love. but you're going to have to pay a customs fee of $9,200. What? So that's the first time she sends money.
好吧。不，不，不用抱歉，萨姆。对。所以他是这样第一次从她身上骗到钱的。他说：我想送你一个非常昂贵的包包来表达我的爱，但你得支付 9,200 美元的关税。什么？所以这是她第一次汇钱。
Did she get the purse? I don't know. It wasn't in the article. I had that same question. So then he starts to say, I've been diagnosed with kidney cancer, and I need money for hospital treatments because my bank accounts have all been frozen in my divorce. Is this Jennifer? Aniston divorce or Angelina Joe Lee divorce?
她拿到那个包了吗？我不知道。文章里没写。我也有同样的疑问。然后他开始说：我被诊断出患有肾癌，我需要钱做住院治疗，因为我的银行账户在离婚诉讼期间全部被冻结了。这是詹妮弗·安妮斯顿离婚还是安吉丽娜·朱莉离婚？
Angelina Jolie divorce. Okay. Did that matter? I mean, I did reset. They have that rosé. The winery? Yes, they have a winery and it's been very heated about it. Yeah, but I'm still not believing he has no income.
安吉丽娜·朱莉离婚。好吧。这有什么关系吗？我的意思是，我重新查证过。他们有那个桃红葡萄酒。酒庄？对，他们有一个酒庄，而且关于这个闹得沸沸扬扬的。对，但我还是不相信他会没有收入。
But also like, he has a lot of very rich famous friends. He can't ask George Clooney for money for his hospital treatments. Yeah. His agent can't front him some money if his stuff is frozen. Whatever, this woman wasn't thinking like that. He starts sending photoshopped photos of himself from the hospital. Her name was Anne, and one of the pictures is a picture of Brad Pitt holding a sign that says, I love you, Anne.
而且，他有很多非常富有且知名的朋友。他怎么就不能找乔治·克鲁尼借钱做手术呢？对。如果他的资产被冻结了，他的经纪人难道不能先给他垫付一点钱吗？不管怎样，这个女人当时根本没这么想。他开始发送自己 P 图的在医院的照片。她叫安（Anne），其中一张照片是布拉德·皮特拿着一块牌子，上面写着“我爱你，安”。
Oh, my gosh. But Brad Pitt does not look sick in any of the pictures. He's like always smiling. His, wait. Sam. I need to see this picture. What is, how old is Anne? She's 53.
哦，天哪。但布拉德·皮特在所有照片里看起来一点都不像生病的样子。他总是面带微笑。等等。萨姆。我得看看这张照片。安多大了？她 53 岁。
Oh, God. She's our age, lady. Oh, no. Let me see. I feel so bad for Anne. Does she tell any of her friends? I mean, one of the pictures is like from surgery. Like he literally has two surgeons over him.
哦，天哪。她和我们同龄，各位。哦，天哪。让我看看。我真替安感到难过。她把这事告诉过她的朋友吗？我的意思是，其中一张照片就像是手术时的场景。就像他 literalmente（字面意思）有两名外科医生围在他身边。
Here. Oh, honey. Oh. His head doesn't look right on his body. No, and then there's also just like a weird, like, hospital gown on top of him. Yeah, there's one picture where the surgeons are fully in all their gear with little glasses on, and they're operating on him. Yes. But he looks like he's fresh off the red carpet.
给你。哦，亲爱的。哦。他的头安在身体上看起来怪怪的。不对，而且他身上还穿了一件看起来很诡异的病号服。对，有一张照片里，外科医生们全副武装，戴着小眼镜，正在给他做手术。对。但他看起来就像刚走完红毯一样。
Yes, in all the pictures. Oh, no. Where were her friends? Didn't she tell people? Wasn't there someone who was like, Anne? I don't think it's Brad Pitt. I don't, because this went on for 18. months. Wow. And they never found the scammer. No. Yeah. No, she came out. The reason she started speaking
对，在所有照片里都是。哦，不。她的朋友们都在哪儿？难道她没告诉别人吗？难道就没有人说：“安，我觉得这根本不是布拉德·皮特”吗？我不觉得，因为这持续了 18 个月。哇。而且他们从来没抓到过那个骗子。没有。对。不，她站出来了。她之所以选择发声，是为了防止其他人被骗。她曾经有机会见到布拉德·皮特吗？我觉得没有。那对布拉德·皮特来说倒是一件暖心的事。你知道他可以做什么。我的梦想，给她带碗汤。她一定会高兴坏了。或者也可能不会。也许这会让她触景生情。也许会的。也许她再也无法看任何布拉德·皮特的电影了。你能想象吗。但话说回来，怎么会这样，他总是出现在新闻里。他一直在拍电影，走红毯。难道就从来没有什么类似“嘿，你是怎么在刚做完肾手术没多久就拍好那部 F1 电影的”这种新闻吗？对。我敢肯定他当时会说：“除了你，我没把我有肾癌的事告诉任何人。”而且他们从来没抓到那个人。没有。哇。对。好吧。埃斯梅拉达绝对是遇上网恋诈骗了。
out was to prevent other people from being scammed. Did she ever get to meet Brad Pitt? I don't think so. That'd be a nice thing for Brad Pitt to do. You know what he could do. My dream, bring her some soup. She'd be so delighted. Or maybe not. Maybe it'd be triggering. Maybe it would. Maybe she can't watch any Brad Pitt movies anymore. you imagine. But also like, how was that, he's always in the news. He's always making movies and on red carpets. Like, was there ever anything like, hey, how did you do that F1 movie so fresh out of the hospital? Yeah. I'm sure he was like, I'm not telling anybody about my kidney cancer except for you. And they never caught the person. No. Wow. Yeah. Okay. Esmeralda is totally getting catfish.
就像安一样。而且她完全不相信这是演员乔什·哈洛韦。她就觉得：不，才不是。这是贾森。然后她有了一段面对镜头的独白，因为，你知道的，梅尔和其他几个姑娘都在吃吃偷笑，而她觉得她们是在嫉妒。我想让你们听听她的独白。当一群单身女性中有一个女人在爱情中找到了幸福，其他单身女性就会试图把那个幸福的女人拉下水。
like Anne. And she is not at all accepting that this is Josh Holloway and actor. She's like, no, it's not. It's Jarsen. And then she has this talking head because, you know, Maher and the other gals are snickering
你知道的，就像在一锅煮沸的龙虾里，你知道龙虾吗？你知道吗，雄性龙虾会逆来顺受地接受它们的命运，而雌性龙虾会试图逃出去，但在过程中把彼此往下拽？她们休想把这只龙虾往下拽。太绝了。当她说她们在把彼此往下拽时，她真的开始挥舞双手了。对，她开始做抓挠的动作。抓她自己的头发。
and she thinks they're jealous. I want you to hear her talking head. When there is a group of single women and one woman finds happiness in love, the other single women try to take that happy woman down.
这段独白太强烈了。她在里面演得太棒了。但我必须知道，这个龙虾冷知识是真的吗？你们查过吗？因为我真的很想知道。我查了。而且我没有用谷歌搜。好吧。
You know, like in a bowling pot of lobsters, you know, lobsters? Do you know that the male lobsters all lazily accept their fate while the female lobsters try to get out, but, you know, clowing down each other during the process? They will not clow down this lobster. It's so good. When she says they're clawing each other down, she literally starts batting her head. Yeah, she starts like clawing. Her hair.
互联网上是这么说的……我已经用谷歌搜过太多东西了。互联网上是这样说的。好吧。龙虾有神经系统，人们普遍认为它们有能力感知痛苦和经历痛苦。雄性和雌性龙虾在被放入一锅水里时反应不同的这种说法是一个神话，它经常在流行文化中流传并被用作隐喻，但背后没有任何科学事实支持。实际上，两性的龙虾对沸水的痛苦刺激的反应都是通过挣扎和试图逃跑来表现的。
This talking head was so intense. She's so good in it. But I had to know, is this lobster trivia true? Did you look it up? Because I really wanted to know. I did. And I did not Google it. Okay.
我想，还会尖叫。我也有关于这个的说法。听到的声音通常是蒸汽从虾壳里逃逸的声音，而不是尖叫声。尖叫。哦。但由于有强有力的证据表明龙虾是有知觉的并且能够感受到痛苦，包括瑞士和新西兰在内的某些国家已经禁止了将它们活活煮沸的做法，并要求必须先对它们进行人道击晕或杀死。不过无论公龙虾还是母龙虾，它们当然都想逃出锅。对。好吧，现在镜头回到办公区，我们看到不同的同事们正在设置他们的 Latch 个人资料。亚当正在一堆女士资料里滑动浏览，然后看到了一个。
Here's what the... I had Googled so much already. Here's what the Internet has to say about it. Okay. Lobsters have a nervous system and are widely believed to be capable of feeling pain and experiencing distress. The idea that male and female lobsters react differently when placed in a pot of water is a myth, often circulated in pop culture and used as a metaphor, but does not have any scientific fact behind it. In reality, lobsters of both sexes react to the painful stimulus of boiling
那就像是一个他曾暗恋过的女性，艾莉莎（Alyssa），而他的妻子萨默（Summer）告诉他萨默已经去世了。对，就好像那是他的高中暗恋对象，但他妻子说她已经去世了，然后他们送了一个水果花篮给谁？我猜是她的家人。但问题是。我们了解到，亚当的妻子萨默可能有点。占有欲强？控制欲强，占有欲强。嗯哼。
water by struggling and trying to escape. And screaming, I think. I have something about that, too. The sounds heard are typically from steam escaping the shell and not screaming. screams. Oh. But due to the strong evidence that lobsters are sentient and can fill pain, some countries, including Switzerland and New Zealand, have banned the practice of boiling them alive and require that they be humanely stunned or killed first. But both male and female lobsters, they just went out of the pot, of course. Yeah. Well, now out in the bullpen, we're seeing different coworkers set up their latch profiles. Adam is swiping through a bunch of ladies and sees one.
嗯哼。奥斯卡有一个面对镜头的独白，他说这就是为什么他把一切都保持低调，不搞约会软件。但就在他说这话时，他的手机正好开始叮叮咚咚地响起了通知提示音。我在网上看到过，我不知道这是不是真的。那个提示音是 Grindr（同性恋交友软件）的提示音。哦，它有它自己专属的叮咚声吗？我不知道。那是个粉丝理论。
It was like a woman he had a crush on, Alyssa, and his wife Summer told him that Summer had died. Yeah, it was like his high school crush, but his wife said she died and they sent an edible arrangement to who? I guess her family. But here's the thing. We're learning that Adam's wife Summer might be a tad. Possessive? Controlling, possessive. Mm-hmm.
我的 Instacart（送菜软件）有它自己专属的叮咚声。它告诉我我的杂货有变动了。不管怎样，如果这是真的那就说得通了，因为这真的当众揭穿了奥斯卡，说明他很虚伪。他绝对在用约会软件。但这同时也让我们知道了他的感情状态。嗯哼。对。他是单身。好吧，现在内德正在制作他自己的约会软件个人资料。他真的很努力想让它吸引到那个贾森网恋骗子。问梅尔：我可以在个人资料里加一些什么军事术语？梅尔说：嗯，你可以说你喜欢乌贼，意思是海军。然后她说：但我得看看你的全部个人资料。
Mm-hmm. Oscar has a talking head where he says this is why he keeps everything private and doesn't mess with dating apps. But as he says this, his phone just starts dinging with notifications. I read online, I don't know if this is true. That notification is the grinder notification. Oh, it has its own special ding? I don't know. That was a fan theory.
拿来吧你。然后她大声朗读道：我身高可能有一米九三，但我依然喜欢当被抱在里面的那个（小勺子）。然后她笑了起来。是的，什么？不，我只是觉得这挺可爱的。我也觉得挺可爱的。确实。她还翻看了他所有的照片，然后说：你几乎在所有的照片里看起来都很富有。
My Instacart has its own special ding. It tells me there's been a change to my groceries. Anyway, it would make sense if that is true because, that really, like, calls Oscar out that he's being hypocritical. He's definitely on dating apps. But also lets us know his relationship status. Mm-hmm. Yeah. He's single. Well, now Ned is working on his own dating app profile. He's really trying to make it attractive to this Jarsen Catfisher person. Yeah. He asks Mayor, what's some military terms I can put in my profile? And she says, well, you could say you like squids, which means the Navy. And then she's like, but I want to see your whole profile.
你看起来要么很富有，要么看起来像黛安·基顿（Diane Keaton）。对，她说：你跟各种帽子到底有什么仇？这真的把我笑死。我知道。然后她说：什么？这到底是什么运动？这是匹克球（pickleball）吗？你还有你自己的匹克球场吗？
Hand it over here. And she reads out loud, I may be six foot three, but I still like being the little spoon. And she starts laughing. Yes, what? No, I just thought it was cute. I thought it was cute, too. It was. She also sourced through all his photos, and she's like, you look rich in almost all of them.
然后他说：不，不，不。我叔叔装了平台网球场。事实上，他在整个竞选市长活动中用的就是这个，说我们是中产阶级。然后她就说：好吧。听着，还有一件事发生了，那就是德特里克要去找妮可，然后说：好吧，我重新激活我的 Latch 个人资料了。天哪，我有好多消息，包括一条来自 WN. NWO 的天气女主播发来的。
You look rich or you look like Diane Keaton. Yeah, she's like, what is it with you in headwear? That just cracked me up. I know. And then she's like, what? What is this sport? Is this pickleball? Do you have your own pickleball court?
然后妮可就说：你应该和她出去。然后他说：真的吗？我不知道。她今晚想一起出去。我今晚要和你见面吗？妮可说：不。你没有。她对他太冷淡了。
And he's like, no, no, no. My uncle put in platform tennis. In fact, that's what he used on his whole like mayorial campaign is that we're middle class. And she's just like, okay. Well, listen, another thing that has happened is that Detrick is going to approach Nicole and say, well, I've reactivated my latch profile. Gosh, I have a lot of messages, including one from the weather gal at WN. NWO.
她只是在写这封电子邮件。她正在做的是发送一封巨型电子邮件，基本上揭露了埃斯梅拉达正在被网恋诈骗的事实。这是一封尖酸刻薄、充满被动攻击性的邮件。我看了一下。她把它发送给了 433 个人。对。我不明白。
And Nicole's like, you should hang out with her. And he's like, really? I don't know. She wants to hang out tonight. Am I seeing you tonight? Nicole's like, nope. You're not. She's so dismissive of him.
怎么会有人这样做却没被炒鱿鱼，不过也罢。对。她只是想让所有人都知道。但她一边写着这封尖酸刻薄、意在搞垮埃斯梅拉达的邮件，一边又对德特里克像个混蛋一样冷漠。这就是我的重点。我知道。这就是我的重点。比如，除了她对待他的方式，她真的不太好。我知道。我不知道妮可到底怎么了。她到底怎么了？她不是个好人。我其实找到了一篇莫娜（Ramona）接受“有色人种书呆子”（nerds of color）采访的报道。那是一场很棒的采访。莫娜饰演妮可。对。谢谢。她谈到了为什么她认为妮可在表达感情时会如此反复无常。好吧。以下是她角色的背景故事。她说：妮可过去在感情上并没有遇到过最好的榜样。而且她之前曾爱上过一个已婚之人的事实对她造成了很重的心理负担。
She's just writing this email. What she's doing is she's sending this massive email basically exposing the fact that Esmeralda is being catfished. It's a snarky, passive aggressive email. I looked. She's sending it to 433 people. Yeah. I don't understand.
所以她认为正是这一点阻碍了她信任自己并重新走回人际交往中。他们还让她用三个词来形容她的角色，这就是她选的三个词：沉稳、精于算计、敏感。我发现“敏感”这个词让我非常好奇。所以我很想看到更多这方面的展现。对。我很想看到。已经证实了埃斯梅拉达对妮可一直不太友好，而她可能一直在等待某个局势扭转的时刻，对吧？对。
how that doesn't get you fired, but that's okay. Yeah. She just wants everyone to know. But she's doing this snarky email, takedown of Esmeralda, and at the same time, just being an a-hole to Detrick. This is my point. I know. This is my point. Like, in addition to the way she treats him, she's not very nice. I know. I don't know what's up with Nicole. What's up with her? She's not a nice person. I actually found an interview that Ramona did with nerds of color. It was a great interview. Ramona plays Nicole. Yes. Thank you. And she talked about why she thinks Nicole is so fickle with showing her feelings. Okay. And here is her backstory. She said, Nicole doesn't come from the best examples of love in her past. And the fact that she was previously in love with someone who was married really weighed on her.
所以也许这就在这一集里发生了。好了，所以现在埃斯梅拉达要回到办公区了。你猜怎么着？贾森发来了一段视频。而且非常惊艳。这也很明显是一个卡梅奥明星祝福视频。我觉得我们应该放来看看。哦，放吧。
And so that is something that she thinks is keeping her from trusting herself and getting back out there. They also asked her to pick three words to describe her character, and these are the three words she picked, steady, calculated, and sensitive. And I found the sensitive one was very curious to me. So I'm going to want to see more of that. Yeah. I want to see that. It's been established that Esmeralda has not been nice to Nicole, and she's probably just been waiting for a moment for something to turn, right? Yeah.
我有个宣告。贾森刚刚发来证据证明他对我的爱。他是真的。嘿，亲爱的。我是贾森，来让你知道你究竟有多受宠爱，埃斯梅拉达。哦，我也是，我爱你的母亲。看吧？现在我希望这能向你办公室的朋友们证明
And so maybe that happened in this episode. All right, so now Esmeralda is going to come back out to the bullpen. Guess what? Jarsen has sent a video. And it's pretty amazing. It's also pretty clearly a cameo video. I feel like we should play it. Oh, let's.
贾森是真的。贾森没有骗你，贾森爱你。所以，我的甜心刚刚证明了他对我的爱是真的，而且他看起来就像那个叫乔什·哈洛韦的人。这是一个卡梅奥视频。他在视频里用第三人称称呼自己。对，奥斯卡差不多指出了这一点，而埃斯梅拉达却说：大家经常这么做好吗。对。
I have an announcement. Jarsen just sent me proof his love for me. He's real. Hey, darling. This is Jarson to let you know just how adored you really are, Esmeralda. Oh, me too, I love your mother. See? Now I hope this proves to your office friends
埃斯梅拉达觉得如果有人说那种话，那你们才都是大笨蛋。我们收到了来自雷纳塔·C 的粉丝提问。嗨，来自佛罗里达州坦帕市的雷纳塔。她以前也写信来过。雷纳塔想问：他们是怎么请到乔什·哈洛韦来演他自己的？以及为什么会产生用他来作为网恋诈骗对象的剧情构思？嗯，莫说乔什·哈洛韦简直是饰演贾森的完美人选。当他们在编剧室里时，他们想到了他，因为他们想找一个著名的
that Jarsen is real. Jarsen is not scamming you, and Jarsen loves you. So, my sweetie just proved that his love for me is real, and he just looks like that Josh Halloween person. It's a cameo video. He's speaking in the third person. Yeah, and Oscar kind of calls that out, and Esmeralda's like, people do that all the time. Yeah.
演员。一个曾经演过某个著名角色的演员，但如果你刚好没看过那部剧，你可能认不出他来。对。她说这对她来说也是真的。她说：我从来没看过《迷失》。
Esmeralda thinks you guys are all stupid if she said something like that. We got a fan question from Renata C. Hi, Renata in Tampa, Florida. She's written in before. Renata wants to know, how did they get Josh Holloway to play himself and where did the storyline come to use him as the catfish person? Well, Mo said Josh Holloway was just perfect for Jarsen. When they were in the writer's room, they thought of him because they wanted to find a famous
可能埃斯梅拉达也从来没看过。所以他们当时就觉得：这太棒了，因为他在《迷失》里太出名了。然而如果你从来没看过这部剧，那么她可能不认识他这事就完全说得通。对。所以这就是他们决定选用他的原因。而且乔什·哈洛韦从一开始就非常配合。他太棒了。
person who had played a famous person. who had played a famous character, but if you happened to have not watched that show, you might not recognize them. Right. And she said that was true for her. She said, I had never watched Lost. And probably Asmerelda never has either.
而且他在里面演得太好了。完美。真的演得非常好。我们还收到了来自丹佛的马蒂娜·B 的提问，她说：我想知道你们大家有没有过任何网恋诈骗的故事？或者有没有过这样的时刻，你的某个朋友突然说：哦，我看到有人冒充你在网上网恋诈骗别人。嗯，你知道的，这很有趣，马蒂娜。
So they were like, this is amazing because he's so famous for Lost. And yet if you never watched the show, it is believable that she might not know. Yes. And so that is how they settled on him. And that Josh Holloway was just game from the beginning. He was amazing.
我觉得我们两个都曾遇到过别人在 Instagram 上冒充我们的情况。我以前遇到过这种事。比如一个假账号？对，但它不标注自己是粉丝账号。它直接说那就是你。然后他们搜集你的照片并发布出来。对。而且大家一直都特别好。
And he's so good in it. He's perfect. Really, really good. We also got a question from Martina B in Denver who said, I was wondering if you all had any catfish stories. Or was there ever a time when a friend of yours was like, oh, I saw someone pretending to be you catfishing other people. Well, you know, that's interesting, Martina.
比如，如果有人碰巧遇到了，他们会告诉我。然后我就可以说：嘿，伙计们，那不是我。所以我的确遇到过这种情况。但我们问过编剧莫，因为她写了这一集，问她自己有没有被网恋诈骗过。你们知道吗，她真的经历过。她说：我被骗过好多次。她说：我只是诺莫尔（Normal）来的一个笨女孩。她甚至重点讲了一个发生在她和她妻子萨曼莎（Samantha）身上的骗局。
I feel like we both have had people pretend to be us on Instagram. I've had that before. Like a fake account? Yeah, but it doesn't say it's a fan account. It says that's you. And they find photos of you and post them. Yeah. And everybody has always been really nice.
我猜他们是在西好莱坞时被卷入了一场冷冻酸奶骗局。那发生在他们刚开始约会的时候，但这个骗局，这个酸奶骗局，最后竟然把他们一路带到了拉斯维加斯。对。并且她说她给她妻子起了一个绰号。她管她叫“骗子曼莎”（Scamamanta）。对。好吧，莫接着说，她一直试图找个机会把这个故事情节硬塞进某个地方，而且她很高兴自己终于能把这个网恋诈骗的想法写进一集里。
Like, if someone comes across that, they tell me. And then I can be like, hey, guys, that's not me. So I have had that. But we asked Mo, the writer, if she'd ever been catfish because she wrote this episode. And she has, you guys. She said, I have been scammed so many times. She says, I'm just a dumb girl from normal Illinois. She actually highlighted one scam that happened to her and her wife, Samantha.
我的身份曾被拿去试图诈骗别人。我其实很高兴我能把这件事说出来，因为我之前一直不知道该怎么让大家知道。这个人让我的经纪人知道他们收到了一封电子邮件。邮件内容是这样的：你好，希望你一切都好。我叫利亚姆·卡特（Liam Carter），我负责管理珍娜·费舍尔。这不是真的。我的经纪人叫娜奥米·奥登柯克（Naomi Odenkirk）。
I guess they got pulled into this frozen yogurt scam in West Hollywood. It happened when they were first dating, but this scam, this yogurt scam, ended up taking them all the way to Vegas. Yes. And she says she has a nickname for her wife. She calls her Scamamanta. Yes. Well, Mo went on to say that she has been trying to find a place to force the storyline into something. and she was so glad she got to put this catfishing idea into an episode.
根本没有什么叫利亚姆·卡特的人。代表你。在任何方面代表我。听听他们在邮件里是怎么说的。利亚姆，假利亚姆说：我们很高兴邀请你作为嘉宾做客珍娜的播客节目《办公室女士》（Office Ladies），该节目由她与安吉拉·金西共同主持。
My identity has been used to try to catfish someone. And I'm actually happy that I can talk about it because I haven't known how to let people know. This person let my manager know that they had received an email. And here's what the email said. It said, hi, I hope you're doing well. My name is Liam Carter and I manage Jenna Fisher. This is not true. My manager's name is Naomi Odenkirk.
哦，天哪。这是一次付费合作机会。我们将为你参与节目提供 2,000 美元。采访将通过 Facebook 以虚拟方式进行，时长约为 30 到 45 分钟。所以这个人把这封邮件发给了一个人，然后……对，他们对另一个人也这么干了。他们正在做的事情是，他们在把目标对准图书作家。
Nobody named Liam Carter. Represents you. Represents me in any way. Listen to what they said in their email. Liam, fake Liam, says, we're excited to invite you to be a guest on Jenna's podcast Office Ladies, which she hosts with Angela Kinsey.
我猜大概是那些不那么知名的作家。他们走过去说：珍娜很喜欢你的书。她想让你做客《办公室女士》。但接着他们说采访是在 Facebook 直播上进行。这是又一个破绽。我没有那个。对。我们没有 Facebook。
Oh my gosh. This is a paid opportunity. We will offer you $2,000 for your participation. The interview will be conducted virtually via Facebook and run approximately 30 to 45 minutes. So this person sent this email to someone and then... Yeah, so they did it to another person too. And what they're doing is they are targeting writers of books.
没有。对。我们以后可能会弄个 Facebook，但我们现在不在 Facebook 上。对，我们可能哪天会有个《办公室女士》官方 Facebook，但现在没有。我知道。这纯粹是精力问题。但让我困惑的是，他们竟然主动提出付给这位作家 2,000 美元来上播客。当时我就想：什么？
I think probably lesser known authors. They're going out and they're saying, Jenna loved your book. And she wants you to be a guest on office ladies. But then they say that the interview happens on Facebook Live. That's another thing. I don't have that. Yeah. We don't have Facebook.
我搞不懂。这其中有什么阴谋？我知道。哦，还有发送这些邮件的电子邮件地址。是一个 Gmail 地址。所以我还想对所有人说，如果有人说他们代表《办公室女士》或代表我本人，他们绝对不会使用 Gmail 地址。
No. Yeah. We might get Facebook, but we're not on Facebook right now. Yeah, we might someday have an office lady's official Facebook, but we don't. I know. It's just bandwidth. But what's confusing to me is they're offering to pay the author $2,000 to come on the podcast. And I'm like, what?
他们会使用 Odyssey 的邮箱地址，或者会使用威廉·莫里斯经纪公司（WME）的邮箱地址。我所有的代表都有他们自己的——不管那些叫什么来着。比如服务器。企业。服务器。对。没错。我的天，他们还挺具体的。他们给另一位作家发了一封信，上面写着：珍娜非常欣赏你走心的故事讲述，并荣幸地邀请你在 7 月 22 日至 30 日东部时间晚上 8 点之间做客我们的虚拟 Facebook 直播播客。如果这些人真的出现在 Facebook 直播上会发生什么？
I don't understand. What's the catch here? I know. Oh, also the email address. that these are coming from is a Gmail address. So I also just want to say to everybody out there, if someone who says they're representing office ladies or me personally, they're not going to have a Gmail address.
有什么在等着他们？我当时就是这么说的。我们根本不在那儿。利亚姆到底在搞什么鬼？我不知道。我让我的律师去调查这事了。我们查过了，但这对我来说根本说不通。我实在搞不懂他们最终的目的是什么。但各位，那真的不是我。而且，我们也不是那样做事的人。但我看着那些邮件，它们看起来非常专业。看起来非常官方。太诡异了。我知道。所以，是的。我的身份被盗用了。对。这让我很烦。我不喜欢这样。我不喜欢这样。我也不喜欢这样。我们和很多朋友聊过，甚至包括我们的剧组同仁以及我们合作过的不同项目中的伙伴，很多人都在某个时刻遭遇过别人在网上冒充他们。对，还有给别人发私信的。是的，发私信。是的。
They're going to have an Odyssey email address, or they're going to have a William Morris Endeavor email address. All of my representatives have their own whatever those are called. Like a server. A corporate. server. Yes. Exactly. I mean, they got specific. They sent a letter to another author that said Jenna admires your heartfelt storytelling and would be honored to host you for a virtual Facebook Live podcast between July 22nd and 30th at 8 p.m. Eastern. What happens if these people show up to the
这通常会以某种方式导致对方收到金钱损失，而这也是接下来这一幕中将要发生的事情。埃斯梅拉达将继续给贾森汇钱。汇了好多。这让我感到极其不适。就是她一直在狂点发送按钮的那一幕，她一次给她汇 50 美元。哦，而内德在一旁说：求你了，停下，停下。我和内德感同身受。我当时尴尬得脚趾抠地。她一共汇了 450 美元。我数着叮咚声呢。对。在大概 12 秒的时间里转了巨额资金。她觉得这就是她在照顾他。这就是她将此合理化的方式。你知道的，我知道他需要我，我在照顾他，这会让他快乐。而且他让我快乐。好吧，妮可一直在忙的事情之一，
Facebook Live? What's waiting for them? That's what I said. We're not there. What's Liam doing with this? I don't know. I had my lawyer look into it. it. We looked into it and it never really made any sense to me. I didn't understand the end game here. But everybody, it's not me. And also, that's not how we do things. But I'm looking at the emails and they look very professional. They look very official. So weird. I know. So yeah. My identity has been used. Yeah. Which bothers me. I don't like that. I don't like that. I don't like that either. We've talked to a lot of friends, even our fellow castmates and different projects we've worked on, and a lot of people do have people posing online as them at some point. Yeah, and DMing people. Yes, DMing people. Yes.
就是她买了一个乔什·哈洛韦的卡梅奥祝福视频。她打算把它放给所有人看。这是她对埃斯梅拉达的最后一击。我们听听看。你好，埃斯梅拉达。我是乔什·哈洛韦，来自《迷失》、《黄石》，还有那个地下世界背景的剧集《殖民地》（Colony）。总之，你的同事妮可给你在卡梅奥买了这个视频，
It usually ends up with the person somehow receiving money, and that's what's going to happen in this next scene. Esmeralda is going to keep sending money to Jarsen. So much. It made me so uncomfortable. That scene where she just, keeps clicking send, and she's sending him 50 bucks at a pop. Oh, and Ned is like, please, stop, stop. I was with Ned. I was cringing. She sent him $450. I counted the dink. Yeah. So much money in like the course of 12 seconds. She thinks that this is how she's taking care of him. This is how she's rationalizing it. You know, I know he needs me and I'm caring for him and this is going to make him happy. And he makes me happy. Well, one of the things Nicole's been busy doing is,
好让你能亲耳听到我这么说。我不是贾森。我是乔什·哈洛韦。我不是你的男朋友。我不知道我们的脑回路是怎么搭错的。我只是照着他们让我说的话念而已。但我们并没有恋爱。我爱我的妻子杰西卡（Jessica）。
is she has bought a cameo from Josh Holloway. And she's going to play it for everyone. This is her final takedown of Esmeralda. Let's hear it. Hello, Esmeralda. It's me, Josh Holloway, from Lost, Yellowstone, in that underscenes show colony anyway. Your co-worker, Nicole bought this for you on cameo
我很抱歉。夏威夷语的“再见”（Mahalo）。当他说出“Mahalo”时，镜头迅速切到奥斯卡，我太喜欢这个细节了。对。奥斯卡就像在说：我就知道。我就知道。埃斯梅拉达被这一幕打击得面色惨白。她彻底崩溃了。
so you could hear it from me. I'm not Jarsen. I'm Josh Holloway. I'm not your boyfriend. I don't know how our wires got crossed. I just say what they tell me to say on here. But we're not in love. I'm in love with my wife, Jessica.
谢天谢地。她就像是在说：哦。对。而且她感到羞辱。对。而这一集的结尾将定格在埃斯梅拉达独自坐在屋顶上。她在看《迷失》。并且在咒骂。
I'm sorry. Mahalo. I did love that the camera quickly panned to Oscar when he said Mahalo. Yeah. Oscar's like, I knew it. I knew it. Esmeralda is just visibly shaken by this. She is convinced.
她嘴里嘟囔着一堆意大利语。我不知道具体是什么，但她很不高兴。对。内德会上楼去找她。他会说：我真的很抱歉。他可能还会剧透一个《迷失》的剧情。也许我们还是别说出来了，万一你们还没看过《迷失》呢。然后他给了她一个巨大的拥抱。
Thank God. She's like, oh. Yeah. And she's humiliated. Yeah. And this episode is going to end with Esmeralda up on the roof. She's watching Lost. And cursing.
对。他说：你知道吗？我们要发那篇文章，但我们不会把埃斯梅拉达曝光。我们会把她排除在外。我们要保护她。他说奖项可以等。事情就是这样。非常感人的时刻。
She's saying a bunch of stuff in Italian. I don't know what, but she's not happy. Yeah. Annette is going to go up there. He's going to say, I'm really sorry. He might also drop a lost spoiler. Maybe we won't say it in case you guys haven't watched Lost. And then he gives her a huge hug.
而且梅尔确实帮他弄了个人资料，以至于他真的收到了约会邀请，这似乎让梅尔有点吃醋，但他最后并没有和那位女士出去。没有。他说他很忙。对，其实，我记得他说他不喜欢披萨。她邀请他去吃披萨。他说：不。我觉得梅尔和现在之间还会有更多故事。
Yeah. And he says, you know what? We're going to run the story, but we're not going to expose Esmeralda. We're going to leave her out of it. We're going to protect her. He says the award can wait. And there you have it. Very touching moment.
内德，我只想说我确实提前看过了。我已经把接下来的两集都看了。哦，对。你进度比我快。那里面越来越精彩了。真的吗？对。好吧。
And mayor really did help him with his profile, so much so he got asked out, which seems to bump mayor, but then he doesn't go out with the lady. No. He says he's busy. Yeah. He actually, I believe he says he doesn't like pizza. She invites him to pizza. He's like, no. I think there's more coming up for mayor and now.
市长确实帮他塑造了形象，以至于他被邀请约会，这似乎让市长感到高兴，但后来他并没有和那位女士出去。没有。他说他很忙。是的。事实上，我相信他说他不喜欢披萨。她邀请他去吃披萨。他说，不。我认为市长和娜奥米之间还会有更多故事。
Ed, I'm just going to say I did jump ahead. I've watched the next two. Oh, yeah. You're ahead of me. It's getting good there. Really? Yes. Okay.
埃德，我只想说我确实提前看了。我已经看了接下来的两集。哦，是的。你走在我前面了。那里越来越精彩了。真的吗？是的。好的。
I'm like rooting for something that I hope happens in the finale. We'll get to it, you guys. We want to give a big thank you to Mo Welch for chatting with us about this episode. I did ask her if we're going to see more of Kimberly in season two. And she said, yes, Kimbo is back for more in season two. Spoiler alert. She's going to be emotional. I do look forward to that. Me too. She said playing a toilet paper salesperson comes really naturally to me.
我真的很期待大结局里能发生某些事。待会儿我们会聊到，各位。我们要非常感谢Mo Welch和我们聊这一集。我确实问过她我们在第二季里是不是还能看到更多关于金伯利的戏份。她说，是的，金宝在第二季里会带来更多精彩。剧透警告。她会情绪很激动。我很期待看到那个。我也是。她说扮演一个卫生纸推销员对我来说简直太自然了。
Cracked me up. I also want to say thank you to Kathleen Felix Hager, the costume designer for this show. I loved all those details. And she said we can hit her up if we have any questions for the rest of the series. And also, thanks to all of you, please keep your letters coming. Reach out to us. You can go to officeladys.com. You can find the folders to submit a chit-chat question to submit your around the town info and also to send us any questions you might have about the paper we love hearing from you guys and we hope you have a good one see you next week thank you for listening to office ladies office ladies is a presentation of odyssey and is produced by jennie fisher and angela kensi our executive producer is cassie jerkins our audio engineer is sam kefer and our associate producer is annesley bubicosey's executive producer is lea rice dennis Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz.
把我逗乐了。我还要感谢本剧的服装设计师Kathleen Felix Hager。我太喜欢那些细节了。她说如果我们在接下来的剧集里有任何问题都可以联系她。另外，谢谢你们所有人，请继续给我们写信。联系我们。你可以访问officeladys.com。你可以找到文件夹来提交闲聊问题、提交你的城镇周边信息，还可以发送任何关于纸张的问题，我们非常喜欢听到你们的分享，希望你们过得愉快，我们下周见，感谢收听Office Ladies，《Office Ladies》是Audyssey呈献的节目，由Jennie Fisher和Angela Kinsey制作，我们的执行制片人是Cassie Jerkins，音频工程师是Sam Kefer，副制片人是Annesley Bubicosey，执行制片人还有Lea Rice Dennis，《Office Ladies》由Bill Shultz进行混音和母带制作。
Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton创作的《Ruppertry》。本集还没有评论。点击文字稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。